mesdames messieurs bienvenue à ce grand
débat des chefs en direct de Radio
Canada à Montréal un débat très attendu
le seul débat en français qui réunit sur
le même thème sur les mêmes thèmes la
même tribune les cinq chefs bonsoir
Isane Marie duau sans tarder je vous
présente les chefs des partis de gauche
à droite Monsieur G DUP du Bloc
québécois bonsoir Monsieur DUP bonsoir
monsieur st du Parti conservateur
bonsoir Monsieur Monsieur Thomas
mulkerer du Nouveau Parti démocratique
bonsoir Monsieur mulker bonsoir madame
DS Madame Élisabeth m du Parti vert
bonsoir madame m bonsoir madame de et
Monsieur Justin trudau du Parti libéral
du Canada bonsoir Monsieur trudau
bonsoir bonsoir à vous CIN et au nom de
tous les Canadiens je vous remercie
d'être ensemble sur cette tribune c'est
l'occasion rêvé qu'il vous entend tous
en même temps sur les mêmes questions
alors bienvenue à mes côté justement
pour poser ces questions mes collègues
journalistes patrice Roy de Radio Canada
et Boisvert de la presse bonsoir à tous
les deux bonso a-je besoin de oui a-je
besoin de dire que ces questions sont
inconnues des chefs bien
évidemment sur les cinq thèmes de la
soirée que je vous rappelle à l'instant
le gouvernement au service des Canadiens
l'économie la gouvernance démocratie et
institutions l'environnement et le
Canada dans le monde
la formule de ce débat négocié avec les
partis politiques a un seul grand but
favoriser un débat ouvert et direct
entre eux le débat de ce soir a une très
large portée il regroupe un nombre sans
précédent de médias il faut le souligner
pour la première fois le journal La
Presse et TéléQuébec s'y joignent et le
débat est diffusé sur les trois
plateformes de Radio Canada bien
évidemment sur le site internet de la
presse sur Youtube et en traduction
anglaise sur CBC CTV global et le réseau
CPAC mon rôle ce soir est simplement
d'assurer le respect des règles dent
négociées avec les partis politiques
afin de permettre des échanges vifs mais
respectueux alors madamees messieurs je
compte sur votre collaboration les
Canadiens attendent vos réponses
je vous souhaite donc un très très bon
débat allons-y dès maintenant avec le
premier thème de la soirée le
gouvernement au service des Canadiens
depuis le début de la campagne comme à
toutes les campagnes vous faites de très
nombreuses promesses à coup de millions
parfois même de milliards de dollars
elle concerne aussi bien la santé la
culture l'assurance emploi les garderies
la sécurité la citoyenneté et combien
d'autres sujets mais les citoyens ce
soir veulent savoir si vous êtes
vraiment au service des Canadiens et
s'ils en ont pour leur argent la
première question s'adresse à Monsieur
mulker à vous Patrice merci anne-emarie
madame messieurs bonsoir première
question qui concerne un sujet qui
préoccupe les Canadiens depuis toujours
la santé l'explosion des coups vous le
savez force les provinces à couper dans
les service en même temps les fausses
promesses rendent les électeurs malades
ça dans tous les sujets les fausses
première question monsieur mulkerer vous
promettez 7000 nouveaux médecins 200
cliniques médicales alors que les
services de santé ne sont pas gérés par
le gouvernement fédéral est-ce Monsieur
mulkerer Je me permets de le dire un
mensonge ou une promesse irréaliste
merci Monsieur roi nous sommes en train
de faire des propositions qui ont été
bien chiffré qui vont bien sûr se tablir
sur la collaboration et le travail avec
les provinces et territoires monsieur
Harper a refusé jusqu'à date d'assister
à une seule rencontre du Conseil de la
fédération notre priorité c'est
justement des meilleurs services au
public monsieur Harper veut que vous
ayez peur peur des immigrants peur des
écologistes peur de tous ceux qui sont
pas comme lui il veut que vous oubliez
qu'il y a 300000 chômeurs de plus
aujourd'hui que lorsque la crise a
frappé en 2008 il veut que vous oubliez
qu'il a coupé en tout dans tout à la
santé il a coupé à Radio Canada il a
même coupé le service de courrier à
domicile moi je pense que les Canadiens
mérite mieux monsieur Trudeau dans le
premier débat en anglais a dit qu'on
pouvait pas faire confiance au Québécois
avec les règles normales de la
démocratie moi j'ai confiance je suis
certain qu'on mérite mieux qu'on peut
remplacer les conservateurs de monsieur
Harper avec un gouvernement qui nous
ressemble et qui nous rassemble le NPD a
un plan solide et crédible et c'est ça
qu'on présente aux Québécois et
l'ensemble des Canadiens dans cette
élection à chaque question il y a un
débat ouvert de cette fois-ci de 7
minutes alors la première oste à Madame
M la question sur la santé
merci et Monsieur mer je suis d'accord
avec tout beaucoup de vous avez dit mais
les spécifiques de l'assurance
médicament c'est un grand probabilité
pour le
l'économiser nous pouvons économiser 11
milliard par année avec un système
d'assurance médicament c'est facile
qu'on en achète en vrac par exemple
l'pitor mainant coûte au Canada plus de
800 dollars par année mais en
Nouvelle-Zélande
ça coûte le même produit seulement 15
dollars par année qu'est-ce que vous
proposez pour l'assurance médic ben
merci parce que c'est une question très
importante et le NPD a justement la
semaine dernière annoncé qu'on voulait
faire des achats groupés souvent ici
comme Madame me le dit si bien àelle la
raison des milliards de dollars au
provinces et territoire voilà une belle
exemple où on peut travailler ensemble
mais encore faut-il vouloir travailler
avec les provinces et territoires c'est
mon approche je sors de la politique
provinciale j'ai pas de peur de m'assoir
avec des gens des provinces monsieur
troudau oui ben je sais que pour
beaucoup de gens qui écoutent ce soir la
politique fédérale peut sembler très
très loin de vous la réalité c'est que
nous avons mis sur pied un plan qui va
vous aider directement on promet des
baisses d'impôts pour la classe moyenne
payé par une augmentation de d'impôts
pour le 1 % les plus les plus riches on
va donner des allocations de famille
plus généreus pour pouvoir aider ceux
qui en ont besoin en arrêtant d'envoyer
des chècs aux millionnaires et on va
investir dans nos dans nos
infrastructures et dans nos provinces
monsieur do je rappelle que la question
c'était sur la santé tout à fait écoutez
au départ le fédéral payait 50 % en
paiement de transfert pour la santé
c'est rendu à 22 on s'en va vers 18 %.
alors monsieur Harper continue de couper
monsieur truddeau on n'a pas vu son
cadre financier on ne le sait pas quant
à Monsieur molkerer c'est Madame Régine
Laurent la président des infirmières du
Québec qui dit que Monsieur Mar a renié
sa promesse or moi je pense qu'il faut
être clair sur ça il fautevenir tout au
moins à 25 % de paiement de transfert
pour la santé il faut être clair que
c'est une compétence du Québec donc
j'aimerais savoir si les autres partis
sont d'accord avec le droit de retrait
du Québec dans ses propres compétences
dont la santé avec pleine compensation
sans condition parce que le Conference
Board prévoit que d'ici 20 ans le
fédéral aura effacé sa det et que les
provinces seront au bord de la faillite
parce que le fédéral renit son
engagement initial à 50 % monsieur je
dois vous rappeler du bilan de notre
gouvernement nous sommes le premier
gouvernement d'équilibré de budget en N
pas coupant les transferts aux provinces
en les augmentant pour la santé les
transferts ont augmenté de 20 milliards
de dollars à 34 milliards de dollars
cette année ça va continuer à augmenter
à 40 milliards de dollars à la fin de la
décennie et parce que notre budget est
équilibré pour le long terme on peut
garantir ces augmentations de transfert
mais vous avez abandonné l'accord de
santé avec les provinces monsieur Harper
c'est très important de travailler
ensemble pour protéger notre système
universel de soin de santé et c'est
nécessaire de pas de faire les les
travail ensemble avec les Provin on
respecte des compétences des provinces
et augmente les transferts et ça va
continuer
pour on augmente des dollars plus vite
que les provinces les dépenses monsieur
merci Madame ce que monsieur Harper
oublie de mentionner c'est qui est assi
avec les provinces à travers son
ministre des Finances pas pour discuter
c'était même pas à l'ordre du jour il a
annoncé une coupure de 32 milliards pour
répondre à la question de Monsieur ducep
oui le NPD au terme de la déclaration de
cherboc c'est une droit de retraite
pleine compensation et contrairement à
libéraux nous on dit que c'est sans
conditions les libéraux refusent de dire
que c'est sans condition vous monsieur
mul fait plein de promesses où il dirige
exactement ce que les provinces vont
faire c'est drôle de voir un NPD
centralisateur le Parti libéral s'engage
à travailler directement avec les
provinces parce qu'on a des grands défis
au niveau du santé de la santé au niveau
de de de nos notre population
vieillissante il faut augmenter
l'investissement les investissements en
soins à domicile faut aider les
personnes âgées faut travailler avec les
provinces pour développer les solutions
et nous avons un plan pour faire
exactement ça monsieur du c'est très
bien que la que c'est la politique du
gouvernement conservateur depuis
longtemps on respecte toujours les
compétences des provences RESPE
tellement bien que vous essayz avec les
provinces pu vous le annonc une coupure
de 32 milliard c'est même pas à l'ORD du
jour le
des imp et s des déficit permanen Mo
j'imeris que tous les partis s'engag
dire que ça sera 25% en paiement de
transfert du coût total des coûts de
santé c'est à 50 % à l'origine en 66 on
va être à 18 bientôt alors moi je
demande pas quel programme les uns et
les autres proposent mais est-ce qu'on
va atteindre le 25 % avec le droit de
retrait pleine compensation sans
conditions qu'on soit pas obligé de dire
on do on fera ce programme avec de la
façon que l'on veut mais qu'on puisse
placer l'argent là où on le veut puisque
ça relève des compétences du Québec Mons
trudau le Parti libéral va être un bien
meilleur partenaire aux provinces que
Monsieur monsieur Harper l' été pendant
10 ans nous avons besoin de s'asseoir
pour parler des enjeux auxquels les
provinces font face y compris une
population vieillissante et nous au
Parti libéral on a un plan pour
augmenter le supplément de revenus
garanti pour les aînéses les plus
vulnérables de 10 % ça se veut dire 920
dollars de plus par année dans les
poches de nos aînés les plus vulnérables
c'est ça qu'on veut faire pour aider
monsieur mker lorsque nous avons annoncé
monsieur roi notre plan la semaine
dernière c'était important de savoir que
c'était chiffr
c'était appuyé on avait l'écho de
l'ensemble des groupes qui travaillent
dans le domaine parce qu'ils savaient
très bien que lorsqu'on parlait de
nombre x de médecin possible avec
l'argent qu'on était en train d'injecter
c'était tout à fait réaliste alors nous
tout ce qu'on fait c'est réaliste et on
va travailler avec les provinces de
territoire mais dans le casre du Québec
droit de retraite pleine compensation
sans conditions monsieur Harper sur le
Parti conservateur augmente les
transferts sans augmentter vos taxes et
vos impôts et sans imprunter et c'est
pour cette raison que les transferts les
tion de transf au provinces s garantie
pour l'avenirad garanti mais diminuer
diminu rô de gouvernement fédéral
d'allger le fardeau fiscal des provinces
et de travailler ensemble sur autour de
même la même table pour protéger notre
systè sont des augmentations c'est le
directeur parlementaire du budget là qui
a dit qu'on s'en va vers déséquilibre
fiscal extrême c'est lui qui a dit ça a
pas longtemps il y a 2 mois or j'imagine
qu' a fait l'étude de la performance de
monsieur Harper quand il disait ça alors
merci pour ce premier débat ouvert qui
vous engage la prochaine question de
relance est posée par Ibis vert à
monsieur Harper monsieur Harper d'ici
quelques mois le gouvernement fédéral
doit légiférer sur l'aide médicale à
mourir puisqu'il y a eu un jugement de
la Cour suprême à ce sujet vous
personnellement êtes-vous favorable à
l'aide médicale à mourir oui ou non
c'est évidemment c'est une question très
décat les soins de santé les détails des
soins de santé sont livrés par les
provinces on respecte leur jurisdiction
pour à la décision de la Cour suprême on
va poursuivre cette décision on a établi
un comité consultative pour développer
une réponse qui respecte la décision et
qui protège les intérêts des médecins
des patients des personnes handicapées
des personnes des personnes âgées mais
évidemment on doit agir en en on doit
modifier le Code criminel selon la
décision de la Cour suprême et on on va
le faire alors oui ou non la
question le Parti libéral appuie parce
que nous sommes un parti qui comprend à
quel point c'est important de protéger
les gens les plus vulnérables mais aussi
de respecter les droits et libertés de
tous nous avions demandé justement au
gouvernement Harper quand la Cour
suprême a donné sa sa décision de lancer
ses consultations tout de suite et
monsieur Harper évidemment a traîné les
pates a même pas voulu regarder
l'exemple extraordinaire du Québec qui a
démontré qu'on peut faire ça dans le
respect et dans dans la la avec une
délicatesse euh magnifique oui c'est le
problème c'est que le jugement de la
cours suprême il y a presque c'est en
février 2015 maintenant c'est seulement
une date limite de février 2016 c'est
possible d'avoir un loi préparé parce
que le gouvernement monsieur de monsieur
Harper a fait rien le Parlement attend
pour un loi pour débat pour consultation
publique il y a rien c'est clair que la
Cour suprême est clair c'est un c'est un
question des doigts dans les chartes de
doit et liberté on doit le faire le
comité consultatif poursuit son travail
je pense moi que ce travail été fait au
Québec on peut s'en inspirer largement
et c'est un travail exemplaire non
partisan là tous les partis sont
d'accord au Québec et ils ont fait le
tour du Québec ils ont discuté ça de
façon intelligence respectueuse des gens
et je pense monsieur har vous vez vous
inspirer de ça plutôt que de tenter de
contourner le problème c'est très clair
la question est claire il faut agir et
rapidement Monsieur M le travail que le
Québec a fait aussi a mis des gens de
différentes parties autour de la table
je me souviens de Jeffrey cy et de
veréronque Yvon c'était un modèle ma
femme Catherine qui était au Conseil de
l'Ordre des psychologues a participé à
présenter leur point de vue elle
travaille depuis 30 ans en soins
palliatif et en soin de longue durée
donc c'est une question sur laquelle je
suis sensibilisé et c'est vrai que c'est
délicat mais ça nous empêche pas d'agir
le fédéral a la seule responsabilité du
Code criminel et je peux vous garantir
une chose le NPD va faire un vote libre
jamais je contai contraindrait qui que
ce soit là-dessus mais c'est pour ça que
ça doit être une consultation réelle
large et sincère monsieur
trudau cont qu'on soit en train de
parler d'en jeu comme ça mais ça ça
démontre encore une fois que
malheureusement les gens pensent que le
gouvernement fédéral est trop loin de
eux sur tes décisions comme ça nous
pouvons aider directement les familles
canadiennees en baissant les impôts pour
la classe moyenne en les augmentant pour
le 1 % les mieuxanti en faisant des
allocations générales à familial plus
généreus en ne pas envoyant à des à des
familles de millionnaires le
gouvernement fédéral peut faire une
différence pour mettre l'argent dans
leur poche moi j'ai un plan pour faire
ça les autres partis n'ont pas de plan
concret pour aider la classe moyenne à
créer de la croissance monsieur trudau
on attend toujours de voir vos chiffres
et vous avez pas déposé de cadre
financier monsieur monsieur coupé
monsieur laissez-moi finir ma réponse
monsieur personne vous a coupé monsieur
trudau et monsieur Harper sont en faveur
de coupure de plusieurs dizaines de
milliards de dollars pour les sociétés
les plus riches le NPD a un plan pour
augmenter leurs impôts c'est pour ça
qu'on est dans le TR à cause
de la question ce n'est pas les réponses
à la question monur c'est très bien que
nous avons déposer notre cardre
financier parce qu'il nous attaque
dessus tout le temps nous avons fait le
choix de la franchise nousons
pour pouvoir investir dans l'avenir de
notre pays investir no dans nos
communautés monsieur Harper a décidé
d'équilibrer le budget à tout prix et
donc ne peut pas investir dans nosun sur
la question monsieur vous voulez
intervenir sur la question sur la
question de la classe moyenne ce
gouvernement a donné des coupeurs de
taxes et d'impôt la grande majorité pour
la classe moyen on a créé la prestation
univers pour la GE d'enfant utilisé par
des millions de F vous
enyz
pour les can je peux donner une liste et
on va continuer ça en augmentant les
transferts pour la prestation et en
donnant plus de be d'impôt pour les je
comprends bien r sur le cadre financier
est loin de la question mais continuons
sur le cadre financier parce que
monsieur Harper en 2004 vous souvenez on
critiquait les libéraux qui avait
détourné 57 milliards la caise
d'assurance emploi vous étiez engagé
solennellement pas touch à ça or dans
votre budget vous prenez l'argent d'ca
assurance emploi monsieur tro on ne le
sait pas j'ai pas vu votre cadre et
Monsieur molkerer également puis
j'encaise assurance emploi et ça sur ça
je cite monsieur Guy Caron je citez-moi
pas là j'étais en train de citer
monsieur Caron votre porte-parole
financier qui déclarait les surplus de
la caisse sont dans les surplus de notre
cadre financier en d'autres mots les
surplus qu'on trouve dans votre feuille
là budgétaire sont contiennent les
surplus de la caise d'assurance emplo
monsieur
plan not plan la caisse de l'assurance
emploi sera équilibrée et on a on sera
dans une position de réduire des
cotisations salari salariales de 20 %
d'ici
2017 les libéraux et les conservateurs
ont pigé à hauteur de 57 milliards dans
la crise
d'assurance C semain à N au nouveau on a
promis d'instaurer un conseil
d'administration neutre et indépendant
et mettre cette caisse à l'abri de
autres question c'est clair pourqu
nousons réponse à la Cour suprême de
Canada au sujet de
le vous allez invité à répondre à une
autre question cette fois-ci posée
par par Patrice oui merci anneemie on va
poser la question on verra pour les
réponses mais on a suivi vous avez suivi
comme nous tous l'affaire du
nikab depuis une bonne semaine dans
cette campagne monsieur mulker vous avez
longuement expliqué votre position hier
monsieur la question s'adresse à vous
mais s'adresse à tous les chefs puis on
aimerait avoir une réponse là-dessus la
plus précise possible au-delà de la
cérémonie de citoyenneté ne serait-il
pas raisonnable comme une majorité de
canadien le croit que les services du
gouvernement se donnent et se reçoivent
à visage découvert oui ou non Mons trud
d'abord on sait très bien pourquoi on
est en train de parler de cette
discussion là parce que monsieur Harper
et monsieurp veulent jouer sur la peur
et la division encore une fois ma
position est très claire vous la savez
tous vous la connaissez tous je crois
que si un homme ne peut pas imposer sa
volonté de pour comment une femme
s'habille on devrait pas avoir un état
qui impose comment une femme devrait pas
s'habiller je comprends que c'est un une
question qui met bien des gens mal à
l'aise mais pour moi un état est là
l'État est là pour défendre les droits
des minorités défendre les droits de les
femmes monsieur on parle ici d'une
question fondamentale c'est la question
de l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes dans notre société al quand
monsieur tour nous dit qu' qu'on divise
l'Assemblée nationale du Québec est
unanime les libéraux les péquistes les
caquistes Québec solidaire le maire de
Montréal monsieur coder le maire de
Québec Monsieur labon le Maire de sagné
Monsieur tremblé 90 % de la population
du Québec on divise pas on divise pas on
respecte je pense cette volonté
fondamentale qu'ont les Québécois et les
Québécoises de dire les hommes et les
femmes doivent être égaux dans la
société et nous on a proposé un projet
de loi dans je vais terminer je vais
terminer on a proposé un projet de loi
nous dès 2007 demandant est-ce qu' est
pas de vote à visage couvert et monsieur
Harper lui c'est sur l'ermentation
seulement ça arrive une fois dans la vie
moi je m'engage le premier projet qui
sera déposé par le Bloc québécois ça
sera très clair interdire qu'il a vote
visage découvert
àermentation recevoir ou donner des
services publics à visage
couvert les gens à la maison savent très
très bien ce que vous êtes en train de
faire c'est un enjeu que vous croyez
pouvoir pousser pour pour distraire du
fait que vous ne pouvez pas faire une
différence dans la vie des gens nous on
a un plan pour créer de la croissance
économique pour investir dans les
familles c'est de ça qu'on veut parler
so sur Monsieur M monsieur Harper tente
de cacher son bilan en arrière d'cab
400000 bons emplois perdus dans le
secteur manufactuer ça il veut pas en
parler 300000 chômeurs de plus
aujourd'hui que lorsque la crise a
frappé en 200 ça non plus il veut pas en
parler il veut pas parler de tout ce
qu'il a coupé depuis qu'il est là il se
cache derrière cette question tellement
divisive j'ai l'occasion de dire hier je
suis en faveur de la règle existante qui
prévoit qu'une femme doit se dévoiler
avant de pouvoir se faire assermenter ça
c'est évident mais croyez-moi c'est
juste monsieur Harper qui est est en
train de pousser cette question parce
qu'il voit son avantage et je suis
tellement étonné de voir le Bloc
québécois jadis tellement progressiste
en train d'embarquer dans l'arène sur
une telle question si divisive moi je
veux qu'on s'unisse avec un seul
objectif ce donner un gouvernement
progressist se débarrasser des
conservateurs de Stepen Harper ça c'est
ma priorité monsur Harper r notre
position depuis longtemps et quand on se
joint à la famille canadienne on ne on
ne devrait pas cacher l'identité et
c'est la raison pour laquelle
en croire que des nouveaux citoyens
doivent prêement à visage découvert mais
Monsieur M jamais je ne vais jamais dire
à ma jeune fille qu'une femme devrait se
couvrir le visage parce qu'elle est une
femme l'oppression attaquez-vous à
l'oppresseur attaquezvous pas à la femme
monsieur Harper attaquez-vous à
l'oppresseur si vous croyez qu'il y a
oppression là-dedans AZ le courage de
faire ça mais c'est pas en privant ces
femmes de leur citoyeneté et de leur
droit éussir
Lesur nous avons nous les
Canadiens
monur répondre à Monsieur mol une
secondeais entendre madame une femme sur
oui merci prendre ma place vous aussi
bien sûr maisuss je on veut tous
entendre madame monsieur du vous avez
pris assez long plusieurs secondes au
début de ce débat c'est important que
les Canadiens vous entendent je vous
inviterai s'il vous plaît ne pas parler
tous les deux en même tempsou je suis
d'accord avec Monsieur M pu aussi
monsieur trouau parce que c'est c'est
une un faux débat maintenant nous sommes
en plein d'élection campagne d'élection
nous avons les vrais enjeux les vrais
défis au Canada Quel est l'impact du
neab sur l'économie quel est l'impact
ducab sur changement climatique quel est
l'impact duikab pour les chômeurs il est
un faux débat absolument pour les
distraction et pour éviter les débats
sur les vrais défis pour le Canada moi
je pense que l'égalité les hommes et les
femmes c'est pas une distraction c'est
pas un faux débat et Madame PP qui était
votre collègue Monsieur M disait que le
nicable c'est le symbole
deasservissement des femmes il y a eu un
consensus au Québec c'est 90 % est-ce
qu'on va dire que l'Assemblée nationale
du Québec
unanimement est en train de distraire
l'opinion publique pose un faux problème
je pense moi qu'il y a quelque chose là
il faut l'affirmer il faut pas que les
femmes seent public TR personnes qui
sont pr pour gagner des v à Toronto sont
prêt àier l'égalité des hommes et des
femmes laissz répondre en RAF il reste
25 secondes à ce bloc chacun 10 secondes
5 second c'est une question qui va pas
créer d'emploi je défends les droits des
femmes madame pour les droits des femmes
où est l'enquête sur les femmes
autochtone disparu et assass si monsieur
Harper continue à se cacher tout le
monde va comprendre que pour lui c'est
une arme de distraction massive monsieur
la fin le serment à visage dévoilé c'est
juste le au bon sens ça défend nos
valeurs d'égalité et d'ouverture merci
alors c'est un débat certainement
enflammé je vous rappellerai que chaque
thème celui-ci le gouvernement des
Canadiens va se terminer sur la question
la même question à vous C et vous avez
chacun 25 secondes pour y pour y
répondre alors la question est posée par
y bois vert partout au Canada les
gouvernements demandent aux citoyens de
se serrer la ceinture mais pendant ce
temps-là des milliards échappent au
fisqu dans les paradis PSO quel
engagement prenez-vous à ce sujet alors
le tirage au sort à désigné monsieur
Trudeau pour répondre en premier on peut
pas être contre la vertu on est en
faveur de de s'assurer que les paradis
fiscaux ne soient pas utilisés par les
Canadiens on doit travailler avec les
autorité nécessaire pour s'assurer qu'on
est en train de de de s'assurer queil y
a pas de
tricherie monsieur mulker je tiens à
féliciter Brigitte alpin la cinéaste
québécoise qui a fait du bon travail en
mettant ça devant tout le monde dans son
film le prix à payer aussi il y a le
British tax justice Network qui a conclu
qu'il y avait des milliers de milliards
cachés monsieur Harper veut rien faire
c'est son monde à lui moi je vais
m'assurer qu'on va aller chercher cet
argent-là parce que chaque fois qu'on
laisse échapper cet argent- là au fisque
c'est la classe moyenne qui finit par
paturer et payer encore plus de taxes
nous on va aller le chercher cet argentl
merci Monsieur du c'était un des
principaux qu'ot le bloc aé au cours des
ans contre les paradis fiscaux et à ce
moment-là c'était les libéraux qui
étaient au pouvoir on continuer lomené
sous monsieur Harper et moi je pense
qu'il faut s'attaquer en premier lieu
aux banques canadiennes qui ont beaucoup
de filiales dans ces paradis fiscaux et
revoir chacun des traités que le Canada
signe avec des paradis fiscaux ça moi je
pense c'est essentiel à faire et on a
tous les pouvoirs le fédéral a tous les
pouvoirs pour réagir de la sorte merci
Monsieur Madame M oui merci il y a plus
de 100 70 milliards de dollars d'argent
parté en un vision fiscale et on doit le
retrouver c'est c'est un scandale que
nous avons les taxes les les le le
l'argent dans les paradis fiscal c'est
clair que les les impôts c'est essentiel
ici au Canada pas dans les paradis
d'étranger merci madame monsieur Harper
ce n'est pas un secret que nous
favorisons la réduction des taxes et des
impôts mais c'est essentiel que les
riches que les grandes compagnies fait
leur juste part et dans chaque de nos
budgets il y a des des étapes des
milliardes de dollar pour pour retourner
pour éliminer ces paradis fiscaux et on
a on a signé un entente on a conclu un
entente avec nos partenaires de G7 pour
poursuivre ses objectifs merci Monsieur
un peu le second terme de la soirée
l'économie le Canada est en récession
technique les prévisions de croissance à
l'échelle mondiale sont à la baisse
comme au Canada plusieurs Canadiens se
sentent pris à la gorge tellement ils
sont endettés l'écart se creuse de plus
en plus entre les plus riches chez les
plus pauvres tout n'est pas sombre mais
de nombreux travailleurs parmi vous
s'inquiètent pour leur emploi les
citoyens se demandent donc si vous avez
le pouvoir de faire quelque chose pour
améliorer leurs conditions de vie et
surtout leur redonner espoir la première
question est adressée à Monsieur Gill du
Patrice merci
Anne-Marie disons-le clairement de plus
en plus de gens estiment des gens qui
nous écrivent des gens à qui on parle
que les gouvernements n'ont plus
vraiment de pouvoir sur l'économie ou
choisissent d'en faire le moins possible
on vous accuse souvent monsie un peu
d'en faire le moins possible le laisser
faire économique je je vous cite un
chiffre il y a
1300000 pauvre de plus au Canada qu'il y
a 10 ans Monsieur DUP quel sera votre
réelle pouvoir à ta pour améliorer le
sort des gens qui nous écoutent les
chômeurs sociaux alors qu'en plus vous
vous êtes condamné à l'opposition dans
le meilleur des scénari mais vous savez
il y a ici là sur les C il en a qure qui
sont dans l'opposition il y a seulement
qu'un premier ministre donc on pas dire
l'opposition est absolument quelque
chose dont on a pas besoin c'est ce qui
fait en sorte qu' nous sommes une
démocratie on a fait des propositions
continuellement tout le temps qu'on
était là et plusieurs ont été adopté par
exemple en 2008 il y avait une récession
crise économique c'est le plan
d'infrastructure qu'on repris
coalitionent le NPD et les libéraux que
monsieur Harper a repris par ailleurs
lorsqu'il a ouvert la chambre en février
2009 or il faut en période de récession
de crise économique c'est pas le temps
d'avoir des politiques d'austérité il
faut plutôt que l'État investisse par
exemple dans un plan d'infrastructure
qui favorise l'économie de l'avenir
l'électrification par exemple des
transports qui tiennent compte des
besoins du Québec on a donné beaucoup
d'argent à l'automobile mais on a
pratiquement rien donné à la forêt pour
la 2e et la 3e trans formation il faut
également s'occuper de la culture un
dollar en culture apporte énormément
d'argent beaucoup plus que dans beaucoup
d'autres sectursci monsieur monsieur un
peu la premièreoste pour ce débat ouvert
je peux dire que nous sommes évidemment
dans une période d'instabilité
économique mondiale on le sait ça
continue depuis des années mais pendant
cette période le Canada a eu la
meilleure croissance la meilleure
création d'emploi de tous les pays du G7
et vous savez très bien que c'est ici au
Canada où on a les meilleures
possibilités pour l'avenir notre plan
vise des dépenses abordables et
efficaces pour créer des emplois aussi
des baisses de taxes d'impôt pour donner
plus d'argent dans les poches des
travailleurs des familles et et
d'équilibre budgétaire et les autres
partis proposent des dizaines de
milliards de dollars de dépenses
additionnelles ça va mettre en péril la
création d'emplois et notre économie
monsieur Trudeau le Parti libéral un
plan clair pour aider les gens en
détresse en difficulté d'abord 1 million
des aées plus vulnérables vont voir le
Supplément de revenu garanti augmenter
de 920 dollars par année et et par
rapport au au aux enfants pauvres nous
allons sortir
315000 jeunes de la pauvreté en
investissant des allocations plus
généreuses dans les familles qui en ont
besoin en arrêtant d'envoyer des chèqus
aux millionnaires comme monsieur Harper
et Monsieur mulker veulent continuer de
faire ça veut dire 60000 jeunes au
Québec c'est l'équivalent d'un stade
olympique rempli de jeunes qu'on va
sortir de la pauvreté monsieur nous on a
un plan très concret par exemple pour
enlever l'échappatoire fiscal qui
bénéficier au mieuxanti dans notre
société un échapatoire fiscal qui les
permet d'acheter des options d'achat
d'action alors ça c'est 500 millions de
dollars par année et je l'ai annoncé à
l'Institut broadband voilà quelques mois
à l'Institut bradband j'ai annoncé qu'on
prendrait cet argent dollars par dollar
puis on le dédirait exclusivement à
sortir des enfants de la pauvreté je
n'accepte pas que dans un pays aussi
riche que le Canada on a des centaines
de milliers d'enfants qui vont à l'école
le matin sans avoir manger et le NPD va
changer ça madame oui c'est clair que
l'économie maintenant est faible
l'économie maintenant ont besoin
d'investissements grands dans les les
infrastructures des municipalités aussi
pour le mettre sur pied le les
programmes contre les gaz etit de sert
économiser et en même temps euh lance la
transition énergéque tique vers la
nouvelle économie verte et durable et
avec ça on créer les emplois partout au
Canada monsieur Harper le le point
central des plans des partis
d'opposition du NPD des libéra sont des
grosses augmentations de taxes d'impôt
en commençant avec des grosses
augmentations des cotisations salariales
pour les pensions et l'assurance emploi
ça va coûter pour le plan du NPD ça va
coûter un travailleur moyen de qui gagne
600000 dollars par année 1500 dollars de
leur poche on ne peut pas ce n'est pas
abordable pour nos nos travailleurs et
c'est la même chose c'est la même chose
pour les PME les PME s'opposent à ça
parce la moitié des PME disent au
canadais qu'ils vont couper des jobes
avec une t politique alors voer vous
avez interpellé à la fois Monsieur tau
monsieur MILC chacun 30 secondes pour
avant monsieur du le le Parti libéral va
pas seulement aider nos aés vulnérables
pas seulement les jeunes mais on a aussi
un plan d'invest investissement de 20
milliards de dollars sur 20 ans sur 10
ans dans les infrastructures sociaux ce
qui comprend des logements aborda des
logements sociaux on sait que le
gouvernement fédéral se peut d'être un
meilleur partenaire aux municipalités et
aux provinces et c'est exactement ce que
j'ai un plan pour
faire qu' y a une catégorie de Canadiens
qui pay pas le juste part d'impôt c'est
les grandes entreprises les banques les
grandes pétrolières et on va augmenter
le taxes de 2 % ça va donner des
milliards justement pour aider les aînés
dans la pauvreté mais monsieur Harper
sait très bien que le NPD a aussi un
plan pour réduire les impôts des petites
et moyennes entreprises de 11 % à 9 %
parce que nous savons que les PME créent
80 % des nouveaux emplois au Canada je
veux aussi être un champion pour le
secteur manufacturier cette année au
Bourget à Paris il y a pas une seule
ministre du gouvernement de monsieur
Harper qui s'est présenté quand Boeing
veut vendre des avions en Chine c'est le
président auama qui va moi je veux être
ce champion pour le secteur
manufacturier au Québec et au Canada
monsieur laissé échapper 400000 bons
emplois du secteur manufacturier ça
c'est le bilan qu'il essaie de cacher
monsieur monsieur la question monsieur
trud s'il vous plaît monsieur j'avais
dit Monsieur DUP je vais vous donner la
parole mais monsieur 30 secondes pour
vous pu ensuite à monsieuré dès lors que
l'on parle d'économie on parle des
grandes ententes internationales als il
y a cette entente transpacifique
actuellement la gestion de l' sur la
table moi j'aimerais que tous les partis
prennent ici l'engagement de maintenir
la gestion de l'offre entièrement intact
et ne pas signer une entente qui diminue
la gestion de l'offre et j'aimais qu'on
soit clair sur ça parce que c'est sur la
table les agriculteurs sont très
inquiets ça des conséquences sur toute
la société
québécoise on défend toujours la gestion
de l'offre dans des négociations
internationales mais sur des des
coupeurs de taxes pour des impôts pour
des PME notre plan vise déjà notre plan
est en train déjà de couper ses taxes
les propositions de Monsieur mou sont
des augmentations 10 fois plus grand que
ça c'est
féétion can desreises indépendant et les
manufacturi et les exportateurs du
Canada s'oppose au plan de Monsieur de
Monsieur mou pour encourager les gens
d'épargner nous donnons les baisse de
taxes d'impôt pas des augmentations
c'est le parti libéral qui propose de
baisser les impôts pour la classe
moyenne en les montant pour les
mieuxanti monsieur mulka propose
d'augmenter les impôts sur les ronas sur
les gens
ce qui va pas créer d'emplois qui va pas
créer d'investissement et qui risque de
coûter plus cher aux gens qui ont déjà
la misère à joindre les deux bouts c'est
pas ça qu'on a besoin on va aider les
gens directement au Parti libéral si le
fait d'avoir coupé des dizaines de
milliards de dollars comme les libéraux
et les conservateurs l'ont fait créer
des emplois on n'ura pas 300000 chômeurs
de plus aujourd'hui madame dsau la
réalité c'est que leur plan a échoué on
veut que les grandes entreprises payent
leur juste part pour ce qui est de la
gestion de l'ofre j'ai écrit au Premier
ministre il utilise des phrases
maintenant pour dire B j'y pense je lui
ai demandé de protéger et de défendre
intégralement la gestion de l' les
producteurs agricoles les familles sont
inquiets au Québec en Ontario et partout
au Canada et ils refusent de dire qu'il
va défendre intégralement le secteur des
pièces automobile est aussi très inquiet
on a déjà perdu 400000 bonsx emplois
dans le secteur manufacturier on risque
de perdre 80000 autes si fait rien mais
répondez rapidement monie transpacifique
est une opportunité pour le Canada de de
tenir un partenaire de marché de 800
millions de clients potentiels c'est la
raison pour laquelle la grande majorité
de l'économie canadienne favorise une t
entente mais toujours en défend la
gestion de l'offre on défend nos
agriculteur agriculteurs qui ne sont pas
parti qui ne font pas partie de ce
système et défendent t tous les secteurs
dans les négociations vous avez négoci
en catam il n'y a pas un texte pour les
députés et maintenant c'est clair que
laacc transpacifique menance la gestion
de l'OF et aussi menance les diffuseurs
publics et aussi menance et aussi
augmenter les coûts des médicaments
d'ordonance c'est affreux et nous
n'avons
pasationmenté les pays avec lequel
lesquels le Canada a des traité de libre
échange de 5 à 44 en défendant
l'économie canadien et nos secteur can
nécessaire d'avoir un accès de libre
échange au marché mondial à l'avenir 15
secondes 5
secondes
notreé ch avec
l'cre et la
chcore en seulement dansabin sans
parlementair
madame c'est terminé j'aur don la parole
monieurie onendre dans le prochain bloc
messieur ça reste sur le thème de
l'économie et la prochaine question est
posée par boiv à Monsieur trudieur TR
vous promettez investissement de 125
milliards en disant dans les
infrastructures et des déficits pour
relancer l'économie vous nous dites que
vous voulez faire la politique autrement
mais ça ressemble beaucoup à des
vieilles recettes qu'est-ce qu'il y a
d'imaginatif et de particulièrement
original là-dedans au contraire on a
maintenant un gouvernement et un parti
d'opposition qui sont en train de dire
qu'il faut équilibrer le budget à tout
prix or on a des taux d'intérêt à leur
niveau le plus bas de sur depuis des des
décennies euh on on a une une capacité
d'investir avec notre ratio dett PIB et
on a aussi un une économie qui ne
fonctionne pas à à plein vapeur et des
milliers de Canadiens qui n'ont pas
d'emploi c'est un moment pour investir
dans nos infrastructures dans nos villes
les gens sont pris dans les métros ils
sont pris dans les dans les la
congestion il faut un gouvernement qui
est prêt à investir tout de suite et
c'est ce que nous allons faire alors le
débat s'ouvre avec vous d'abord monsieur
du regardezir le fédéral investi 10 fois
moins que le Québec en infrastructure
pourtant des moyens bien supérieurs à
ceux du Québec al il moyens d'investir
maintenant nous ce que l'on propose
c'est la création d'une société des
infrastructures qui peut faire en sorte
que l'argent empinté s'en va sur la
dette et on amortit sur 30 ans par
exemple ce que fait le Québec et les
provinces ce que font les municipalités
également parce qu'il y a des actifs
hein c'est comme une hypothèque bien un
logement bien un achat al ça on pourrait
faire ça sans provoquer de déficit et je
pense moi que c'est la bonne solution
pour faire en sorte d'investir et sans
faire en sorte également en même temps
que l'économie en souffre mais la la
réalité c'est qu'on est à un moment où
les taux d'intérêt sont tellement basses
B et les les l'économie a besoin de
croissance monsieur Harper a le pire
bilan de la croissance économique au de
tous les premier ministres depuis la
Grande Dépression on a besoin d'investir
on a besoin de créer des emplois je suis
le seul à offrir un un plan historique
d'investissement dans nos communautés
oui merci beaucoup madame do écoutez
monsieur trudau est effectivement en
train de revenir sur des vieilles
formule dernière fois que les libéraux
étaient au pouvoir Paul Martin avec qui
lui sa pavane maintenant a coupé 24 %
des transferts sociaux j'étais un des
ministre appelé à gérer cette crise là
les conservateurs sont en train de
laisser une énorme dette écologique sur
le dos des générations future puis
maintenant monsieur Trudeau propose
comme se solution de laisser une dette
monument nouau m c'est pas une dette
Gén nous on veut mettre à ça on veut
assumers responsabilités Tomy Dougl a
pris un en a fait 17 budgets équilibrés
et à amener l'assurance maladie c'est
làdessus que moi je veux taer pour
amener encore une fois des programmes
sociau digne de ce nom mais il vont être
péren soutenable durable pas de la dette
sur le dos des générations
futures maintenant au niveau fédéral
investi en rord dans les infrastructures
15 fois plus grand que la dernière année
de gouvernement libéral et ces montants
vont augmenter dans l'avenir et nous
faisons ça sans augmenter vos taxes et
vos impôts et sans emprontter et ces
fonds sont garantis pour l'avenir c'est
facile c'est facile pour les autres
parties de dire toujours on va dépenser
plus mais si on a un explosion de
dépenses on retournerait comme Monsieur
tourau propose on retournerait au
déficit permanent même quand quand
l'économie est en croissance on va
retourner l'équilibre budgétaire ça va
mettre en P nos emplois nos programmes
et notre économie selon le parti ver ce
n'est pas un grande question d'avoir un
petit déficit ou petit surplus la
question le plus important c'est la
santé de l'économie partout au Canada
pour mettre sur pied les programmes pour
créer less emplois et aussi en nous
devons investir maintenant dans les
infrastructures et aider les
municipalités parce que il y a un fardau
fardau impossible pour les municipalité
partout au Canada les Canadiens savent
les montréalis savent à quel point ça
nous coûte cher quand on est pris dans
la circulation quand il y a pas assez
d'autobus où les lignes de métro ne se
rendent pas là où on voudrait pouvoir
acheter une maison on a besoin d'un
partenaire fédéral qui investit et c'est
ce que nous proposons les autres
choisissent l'équilibre budgétaire à
tout prix et donc l'austérité qui va
venir avec moi je propose de miser sur
notre avenir d'investir parce que des
pays confiants sont tours toujour prêt à
investir dans les outils dont on va
avoir besoin pour l'avenir et les
emplois qui vont venir avec ensite
monsieur mes 35 ans d'expérience comme
gestionnaire m'amène à conclure qu'il
faut plus faire ça mettre les dettes sur
les générations futures fédération
canadien des municipalités le ma de
Montréal veulent ce que nous offrons un
partenariat clair fiable long terme la
vision à courte vue
s NRE rien du tout nous avons un plan
sur 20 ans juste pour la grande région
de Monréal c'est
8,7 milliards de dollars sur 20 ans ça
c'est un
parteniat arrê de faire le arrêtons de
faire comme par le passé laissant ses
dettes sur le dos des générations
futures notre budget équilibré ce n'est
pas à tout prix c'est avec des
investissements record dans les
infrastructures on élimine le déficit
d'infrastructure au niveau fédéral quand
on parle des déficit si on abandonne un
budget équilibré l'histoire est que les
déficits deviennent de plus en plus
grand et ça continua à la fin on coupe
des services on a évité ça au Canada
c'est bon pour notre économie c'est
nécessaire de garder notre budget
équilibré de continuer à faire des
investissements abordables et de
continuer à baisser les taxes et les
impô pour des familles et des
entreprises j'ai posé la question au
tout début moi tous ces partis ont pigé
dans la caise d'assurance loi monsieur
Caron du NPD l'a dit lorsqu'ils ont
présenté leur C budgetaire monsieur
Harper nous dit j'ai sur plus de 1.9
milliard de dollars mais il a pigé 3,3
milliard d'A emploi sinon c'est un
déficit de 1.4 monsieur trudau je ne
sais pas alors j'aimerais qu'il un
engagement très précis on ne prend plus
un sous dans une caisse ou le fédéral
mais pas un sou ça appartient aux
travailleurs ça appartient à ceux qui
malheureusement perdent leur emploi et
j'amais qu' un engagement ferme ici de
pris ce soir pour une caisse autonome et
qu'on s'engage à ne plus piger dans la
caiss d'assurance emploi est-ce que vous
voulez répondre à Rafal chacun 5 second
le Parti libéral s'engage à réduire les
cotisations pour les travailleurs et de
diminuer le délai de carence d'une
semaine pour aider àiro le pour les on
pay c'est clair que nous nous avons
besoin des investissements dans les
municipalités dans les infrastructures
pas simplement pour les infastructures
mais pour les stimulation d'économie
monsieur les libéraux et conservateurs
ont piqué 57 milliards et c'est avec ça
qu'ils ont payé les réductions d'impôt
aux grandes entreprises un déficit
important pendant la crise financière
maintenant on équiliible la caisse de
l'assurance emploi en crée un petit
suppu et on va réduire les cotisations
salariales par 20 % d'ici 2017 merci le
temps écoulé autre question de relance
avec Patrice monsieur un peu avec un
baril de pétrole à 40 dollars on l'a
beaucoup beaucoup dit depuis plusieurs
semaines c'est comme si votre édifice
économique s'était effondré là vous
promettez
1300000 nouveaux emplois pour les qu
prochaines années ma question est simple
où est le plan pour
diversifier l'économie canadi autrement
dit où
envoyez-vous tous ces nouveaux chôerss
qui sont venus de partout au Canada pour
aller travailler dans le pétrole par
exemple à Ford mcmuray on fait on fait
trois choses premièrement on investit
dans l'infrastructure on l'a discuté on
aussi donné des incitatives pour
encourager l'innovation et le
développement de secteur manufacturier
j'ai annoncé deux autre étapes pendant
ces campagne c'est un plan appuyer nos
efforts dans cette ce secteur appuyé par
la association des manufactuers et
exportation du Canada et on voit
maintenant la croissance de ce secteur
c'est c'est c'est très bien on voit la
croissance de nos exportations dans ce
secteur aussi on appuie l'entraînement
l'entraînement des gens c'est nécessaire
de faire toutes ces choses pour
continuer économie équbré la minute est
écoulé le débat s'ouvre à vous 5
maintenant prièrep à Monsieur M merci
Madame D monsieur Harper a mis tous nos
économiques dans un seul le panier de
l'extraction du gaz et du Pétrole et là
il a échappé le panier il cherche tous
les excuses la faute est la sienne il
savait qu'on était en train de vider le
secteur manufacturier on a perdu 400000
bons emplois dans le secteur
manufacturier ça c'est le résultat qu' a
créé c'est-à-dire une économie moins
diversifiée moins robuste moins stable
nous on propose de travailler tous les
secteurs y compris le secteur du gaz et
du pétrole mais s'assurant du même coup
qu'on maintient pour l'avenir une
économie plus
stable
par exemple nous nous avons besoin
d'investir dans notre secteur
manufacturier nous avons besoin d'aider
c'est pour ça entre autres que je
propose qu'on annule les F35 pour qu'on
puisse avoir des contrats qui vont
amener plus d'emplois ici au Canada et
dans le secteur manufacturier
aérospatial par exemple monsieur Harper
continue d'insister qu'on doit payer des
dizaines de milliers de dollars plus
chers et monsieur mulker est d'accord
avec lui nous de limiter un un appel
d'offre à un prix plafond c'est
responsable on va créer des emplois dans
l'aérospatial en étant plus intelligent
à la façon qu'on va chercher nos
équipements c'est clair que monsieur
Harper est mauvais gestionnaire
maintenant les bonnes nouvelles viennent
des secteurs économiques qui il a oublié
il y a quelques années c'est le secteur
manufacturé le secteur forestier le
secteur agricole des pêcheries
l'économie numérique et l'économie le
potentiel énorme d'économie nouvelle
avec les technologies propre c'est clair
que les les bonnes nouvelles viennent
des secteurs que Monsieur monsieur
Harper avec son gestion son vision en
oublié h monsieur moi moi je je pense
que monsieur Harper a a tout miser sur
sur le pétrole son plan économique
repose sur le pétrole essentiellement
avec les conséquences que l'on voit
actuellement or il il importerait je
pense de mettre fin aux privilèges
fiscaux des grandes pétrolières un
système fiscal qui est plus avantageux
au Canada qu'il ne l' au Texas ça ça
c'est pas des blagues or moi j'aimerais
que tous les partis s'engagent parce que
les banques et les pétrolières paient
plus d'impôts ce sont des gens qui ne
partiront pas hein du Canada évidemment
parce que le pétrole est ici et les
banques ont besoin de resto au Canada s
veulent avoir des clients c'est évident
également al ça prendrait un engagement
très clair de tous les partis sur ça
monsieur maintenant tous les secteurs
sauf principalement le secteur
énergétique son sont en croissance c'est
à cause de plusieurs mesures que ce
gouvernement a pris prend prend de DEP
prend des années dans chaque budget et
le secteur manufacturé travaille avec
nous dans un partenariat pour développer
ces programmes ils appuyent ces
programmes le secteur manufacturé
s'oppose aux augmentations de taxes
d'impôt proposé par le NPD surtout et
les libéraux et c'est ça c'est leur
position le les augmentations salariales
dans le secteur manufacturer va coûter
l'économie 100000 emplois c'est ce que
le secteur manufacturier a
dit manufactu a besoin a besoin de route
et de pont en santé pour de qualité pour
qu'on puisse rendre nos produits vers
les marchés or on est régulièrement en
train de voir que le déficit en
infrastructure empêche les compagnies
d'investir empêche les emplois d'être
créés nous avons un plan pour investir
tout de suite des sommes historiques en
infrastructure pour qu'on puisse créer
des emplois et donner des opportun ité à
nos manufacturiers de réussir Monsieur M
justement parce que les entreprises ont
besoin des infrastructures comme les
routes et les ponts faut que ces
entreprises commencent à payer leur
juste part d'impôt mais monsieur Harper
a eu comme seul ça va pas créer d'emplo
monsieur de réduire par des dizaines de
milliards de dollars l'impôt des grandes
sociétés au Canada et si monsieur Harper
avait raison que c'était ça la recette
on aurait pas 300000 chômeurs de plus
aujourd'hui qu'en 2008 lorsque la crise
a frappé il y a pire la banque CIBC une
des plus grandes au Canada dit que la
qualité d'emploi aujourd'hui est très
précaire le pire la pire qualité
d'emploi depuis une génération c'est
confirmé dans d'autres études et ça
aussi c'est le bilan de Monsieur har
c'est la même chans la même chanson du
NPD on va équilibrer le budget par des
augmentations des taxes et d'impôt ça
n'équilibre pas le budget ça élimine
élimine des emplois on a vu ça en
Ontario en cour bretanque maintenant on
a le secteur manufactur
lui-même sose des plans d'augmentation
de tax
d'impôt
pour les impôts seront en dessous de la
moyenne enous des conservateur même avec
notre
augmentation n'importe quoi au
Canadien
jeloisement pas
les les règles fiscales pour les
pétrolières et les banques ça c'est
clair les manufacturières ça il faut
faire attention parce que ça
effectivement des compagniers peuvent
quitter mais certainement pas les
banques et les pétrolières et c'est ce
qu'on propose exactement alors le thème
de l'économie va se clore sur cette
question la même question aux cinq chefs
vous avez chacun 25 secondes pour y
répondre et c'est i bois vert qui la
pose l'endettement des Canadiens atteint
des sommets monsieur DUP vous parlez
d'impôt aux banques mais êtes-vous prêt
à imposer un plafond de taux d'intérêt
pour les cartes de crédit madame mais
est désigné pour répondre la première
oui si j'ai bien compris les questions
c'est la question de l'impôt sur les
cartes de crédit nous sommes absolument
prêtes de le faire c'est important pour
le consommateur nous avons partout au
Canada pour les pour les pour les
familles pour les pour les gouvernements
un niveau de dette insupportable c'est
unve grave menace pour à
si le niveau d'intérêt va augmenter
monsieur Trudeau nous on a un plan pour
mettre plus d'argent dans les poches des
gens il faut évidemment travailler avec
les banques et avec tout le monde pour
s'assurer que les gens n'ont pas un trop
gros fardeau de dette mais c'est pour ça
que nous on va mettre plus d'argent dans
les poches des familles de la classe
moyenne parce que c'est ça dont on a
besoin pour créer la croissance
économique sur le plafonnement des taux
de crédit oui le NP un plan pour
plafonner les taux des cartes de crédit
chose que de toute évidence monsieur
trouau n'est pas prêt à faire mais il
est prêt à dépenser des milliards sur
dos des générations futures il fait une
longue liste puis pour tout le reste il
y a MasterCard nous on ve être des
gestionnaires responsables on a un plan
crédible long terme pour être des vrais
partenaires pour les villes pour les
provinces contrairement à Monsieur
Trudeau qui a une vision à très courte
vue qui témoigne de son inexpérience
monsieur harp c'est vrai que les dettes
des Canadiens augmentent mais les à tout
des Canadiens augmentent plus vite que
ça et la réalité est que le taux de
faillite parmi nos familles sont à un
niveau bas historique pour la question
des des des cartes crédit on travaille
toujours avec les banques avec les PME
avec les consommateurs pour avoir des
règles qui sont propres pour tout le
monde merci Monsieur du FA mettre un
plafond faut mettre un plafond au carte
de crédit auto exigé mais il faut
également s'occuper du prix de l'essence
à la pompe et donner au Bureau de la
concurrence les moyens d'intervenir
parce qu'on voit toujours dans les
grandes fins de semaine le prix de
l'essence mon or il y a un tau un profit
qui se fait lors du du raffinage al
c'est là qu'il faut intervenir il faut
que le Bureau de la concurrence puisse
par lui-même intervenir et mener des
enquêtes merci alors de l'économie nous
passons au troisème thème la gouvernance
la démocratie et les institution près de
40 % des Canadiens n'ont pas voté aux
dernières élections fédérales est cela
le signe d'un BRI de confiance envers
les partis envers les institutions qui
sont au fond la clé de voe de notre
démocratie
transparence intégrité imputabilité
liberté sécurité sont les mots clés de
ce prochain thème la démocratie
canadienne est-elle malmenée les
Canadiens attendent des réponses
saurez-vous regagné leur confiance à la
tête d'un gouvernement la question
s'adresse à Madame mais d'abord et c'est
Patrice ro qui la pose nous aurions aimé
et je le dis aux gens qui nous écoutent
aussi qui nous regardent nous aurions
aimé peut-être ne pas parler du Sénat
canadien dans un débat lors d'une
campagne électorale avec des sujets
beaucoup plus concrets mais les
Canadiens je pense puis je m'excuse pour
mes enfants qui écoutent je vais
utiliser un mauvais mot mais les
Canadiens ont été dégoûtés par tous ces
scandales de dépense au Sénat madame
mais comme monsieur mulker vous
souhaitez l'abolition du Sénat mais pour
ça vous savez que ça prend l'accord
unanime de toutes les provinces au
Canada on peut pas abolir le Sénat euh
vous le savez mais je le dis aussi au
bénéfice des gens alors une question qui
est très simple êtes-vous prête je pose
la même question monsieur mulker
évidemment êtes-vous prête à lancer une
ronde de négociation constitutionnelle
qui inclurait forcément la question du
Québec et la question docteur
pardonnez-moi mais la position du Parti
vert ce n'est pas pour l'abolution de du
Sénat c'est pour leformme du Sénat pour
un sénat qui était élu et élu par vote
proportionnel ça c'est la positionition
du parti ver c'est difficile évidemment
à cause de la Constitution pour moi-même
je pense que le le chose le plus urgent
pour réforme de notre système de
démocratie c'est pour réduire le pouvoir
de bureau de Premier ministre et ça
c'est possible seulement dans le chambre
de commune c'est pas nécessaire d'ouvrir
la Constitution pour rendre les grandes
réformes dans les chambre de commune
merci Madame et le débat s'ouvre
première rpostste à Monsieur trudau
monsieur mulka a été très clair il veut
lancer une méga onde de de débat et de
négociation sur la Constitution pour
pouvoir éliminer le Sénat moi j'ai
démontré que malgré ces promesses malgré
les promesses de Monsieur mulker de
monsieur Harper qui n'a pas respecté il
les a brisé 59 fois de pas nommé de
sénateur nous avons démontré qu'on peut
réformer le Sénat en enlevant la
partisanerie et le favoritisme politique
en faisant un choix de de de écartter
nos sénateurs libéraux de notre cocus ça
a été une action concrète ça a pas exigé
les négociations constitutionnelle
interminable qui nous annonce monsieur
mulker avec son plan monsieur mul entend
des autres partis madame du on est pris
avec la Constitution puis les reliques
de 1867 vous souvenez qu'on avait des
commissions scolaires religieuses ici au
Québec à venir il quelques années
communuté anglopone éta inquiète j'ai
travaillé làdessus à l'Assemblée
nationale je suis fier de ça on a réussi
à faire adopter à l'Assemblée nationale
à la Chambre des communes et au un
changement et aujourd'hui on a des
commissions scolaires linguistique on
peut aussi actualiser nos institutions
démocratiques le Sénat est c'est passé
c'est vétus c'est de notre passé
historique britannique des non élus qui
font et défond les lois moi j'étais
tellement scandalisé lorsqu'une loi sur
les changements climatiques le plus
important sujet que aucun Premier
ministre va jamais avoir à traiter pour
les prochaines années a été renversé par
un sénat non élu c'était la loi de Jack
Layton je me suis promis de m'assurer
que le 19 octobre j'aille chercher un
mandat avec les électeurs du Canada pour
commencer le processus de travailler
avec les provinces pour nous débarrasser
enfin de cet endroit qui ne sert qu'à
mettre des anciens libéraux et les
anciens conservateurs dans une sinicure
avec une pension que j'ai changé
monsieurs il faut il faut rétablir les
faits c'est madame Marois qui a réussi à
changer cette loi ses commissions
scolaires et c'est un changement
bilatéral ce que vous proposez c'est pas
du tout la même chose ça demand
unanimité des provinces et le Québec a
dit non l'Ontario a dit non les
Premières nations veulent avoir leur mot
pour
tion desandes duébec etautesinces
desières nation ça très clair et si
Monsieur mol parleinstitution vetus moi
je commencerai également par la
monarchie il y a pas grand monde qui qui
en veut au Québec la monarchie je sais
pas s'il y a beaucoup d'AD la monarchie
ici mais je une chose certaine le jour
où le Québec c'est un pays indépendant
onur pas Monarch onur pas non plus
Monsieur M de l'Assemblée nationale àép
VI travailler le dossier mais c'est
étonnant d'entendre le même Gill DUP qui
a voté cinq fois à la chambre de
communes pour l'abolition du Sénat
aujourd'hui dire ah c'est vraiment très
difficile monsieur Harper s'est fait
élire est devenu chef du Parti
réformiste avec une promesse de se
débarrasser du Sénat s'il pouvait pas le
reformer aussitôt qu'il a appris que
c'était trop difficile de le reformer au
lieu de travailler encore il a jeté des
Ponge moi je veux commencer le 19
octobre avec un mandatct nous
débarrasser je ne rencontre pas des
Canadiens qui veulent retourner à
l'époque des négociations
constitutionnelles et sur le sujet de
Sénat il n'y a pas de consensus parmi
les provinces ni pour la polition ni
pour la réforme ce que nous faisons
maintenant il y a 22 vacances au Sénat
on peut laisser ses sièges vacant et on
est en train de réduire les dépenses du
Sénat on a déjà réduit ses dépenses par
6 millions dellar ça va continuer ça
c'est maintenant sans un consensus des
provinces c'est la meilleure façon à
faire monsieur Harper a promis de ne
jamais nommer de sénateur il a brisé
cette promesse sa première journée en
tant que Premier ministre et ensuite 58
fois après ça on le sait très bien que
des négociations avec les provinces sur
la constitution c'est pas ça que les
Canadiens veulent moi quand je m'assois
avec les les provinces si je deviens
Premier ministre je vais vouloir parler
d'environnement et de changement
climatique je vais vouloir parler de
santé je vais vouloir parler d'emploi
pas de la Constitution et que Monsieur
promett des négociations
constitutionnelles qui commencent tout
de suite je trouve ça complètement en
dehors des priorités des Canadiens
monsie ouais vous savez la Constitution
est pas amendable on se comptera pas dit
soir on a tenté avec Charlot et les
Québécois ont refusé par passé et les
canas ont refisé parce que ça trop pour
le Québec al c'est une constitution qui
n'a jamaisé acceptée par l'Assemblée
nationale du Québec tant par les
libéraux que par les péquistes he c'est
très clair on nous a imposé cette
Constitution il y a pas eu de référendum
il y a pas eu de question et et le
Québec doit vivre avec ça si c'était
l'Ontario ça fait ça serurait jamais
passé ça aurait jamais passé parce qu'on
aurait dit c'est impossible qu'on laisse
l'Ontario de côté le Québec on l' laissé
de côté la leçon qu' on en tire c'est
que c'est pas changeable on l'a essayé
et la seule façon pour les Québécois les
Québécoises de sortir de ce ce problème
là c'est de se donner pays monsieur du
c'est débat passé date madame la
souverainé passé date pour le Canada
c'est ça que vous me dites c'est une déb
la consti Canada c'est une déb dat les
gens pr c'est très important pour le
Canada que la souveraineté c'est pas
important pour leébec
monsur oui je veux souligner que le plus
grand scandale du Sénat c'est l'exemple
que Monsieur macker a mentionné quand le
projet loi C31 sur le changement
climatique c'est présenté par mon
collègue monsieur Bruce mais il est
rejeté par le sén à cause de leses que
monsieur Harper comme Premier ministre a
exigé que le Sénat rejeta ce projet loi
sans étude pas de témoignage seulement
parce que monsieur Harper déteste d'agir
contre le gaz effet de serre il est
contre Kyoto et à cause de ça le sénate
agir contre un loi qui était accepté par
la chamb rest minute de ce thème 20
secondes monsieurp pour rliquer notvons
il y a un nombre raccord de projets de
loi et maintenant des députés privés qui
ont été été adopté par le parement
canadien y compris un projet de loi de
madame elleemême monsieur trudau ok on
voit que ce débat qui dans lequel on
sombre va pas créer des emplois va pas
répondre à vos priorités à la maison on
veut investir on veut vous donner des
baisses d'impôts les gens s'embourbent
dans des discussions de constitution de
souveraineté d'identité à la place on
peut parler de comment on va bâtir une
économie plus forte pour la classe
moyenne pour ceux qui travaillent fort
pour s'y joindre monsieur ça fait 150
ans que les Canadiens font dire qu' nont
pas d'autre choix quand ils sont annés
du scandale desandit libéux sont obligés
de retourner au conservateur quand ils
sont annés du scandale du Sénat des
conservateurs cette fois-ci il y a une
autre option cette fois-ci un réel choix
un gouvernement du NPD pour remplacer
les deux vieux partis merci Monsieur
mulker la question de relance adressée à
Gill du à Monsieur du Paris
Boisvert l'Écosse et la Grande-Bretagne
ont accepté le principe du 50 % plus 1
lors du référendum de l'an dernier mais
Londres avait approuvé la question
référendaire est-ce que vous acceptez le
principe selon lequel le Québec devrait
négocier une question référendaire avec
le premier ministre du Canada moi je
vous dirais que ça prend une question
qui sera acceptée parce que ça sera plus
facile et la vraie question c'est
voulez-vous que le Québec devienne un
pays indépendant la dernière fois on a
mis le partenariat dans la question si
on l'avait pas mis on nous a approché
d'avoir parlé du partenariat du durant
la campagne et ne pas l'avoir mis dans
la question là on sait qu'on veut pas le
mettre dans la question al ça me semble
une question claire voulez-vous que le
Québec devienne un pays indépendant et
qu'on respecte le 50 % plus 1 je pense
moi ce que c'est la règle fondamentale
en démocratie très clairement je vois
pas comment le Canada pourrait refuser
de négocier parce que au Québec de
décider de la question mais le Canada
pourrait dire on veut pas négocier on na
pas aimé la question al je vois pas une
question aussi claire que celle-là
voulez-vous que le Québec devienne un
pays indépendant comment le Canada
pourrait refuser de négocier ça me
semble très clair mais il faudrait
cependant que le Canada respecte la loi
référendaire et non pas dépenser plus
qu' qu'il n'en avait droit la dernière
fois et monsieur molker qui qui dit qu'
partip à cette a accepté que le fédéral
outrepasse les déf du on ouvre le débat
monsieur MKA soyons clair les règles
normales de la démocratie valent autant
au Canada qu'ailleurs j'étais à basouri
d'entendre monsieur Trudeau ouvrir le
débat en anglais en disant qu'il ne
faisait pas confiance au Québécois avec
les règles normales d'une démocratie
c'était pourtant les règles lors du
référendum en 80 et du référendum en 95
j'y étais je me suis battu pour garder
le Canada uni j'ai pas de laçon à
recevoir de qui que ce soit là-dessus
parce que je pense que c'est mieux pour
tout le monde de rester dans ce grand
ensemble mais je respecte la démocratie
je suis une démocrate et je n'accepte
pas que ce qui vaut justement pour les
cas et l'Angleterre ne soit pas appliqué
ici Monsieur Trudeau dit que ça va
prendre beaucoup plus qu'une majorité
mais il refuse de dire combien monsieur
trudau d'abord moi j'ai dis la même
chose en français et en anglais monsieur
Harper monsieur mulker aime bien en
parler en français il parle pas du 50 %
+ 1 en anglais moi je suis la Cour
suprême du Canada je trouve qu'un
premier ministre qui néglige et qui se
bat avec la Cour suprême ça fait 10 ans
qu'on en a un la Cour suprême a a dit
unanimement que un seul vote ce serait
pas assez pour séparer Lebec du Canada
et un premier ministre du Canada se doit
de se battre pour l'unité du pays et ça
surprend personne c'est ce que je vais
faire c'est faux la Cour suprême dit
qu'il faut être clair au niveau
qualitatif la question par exemple la
manière de compter les votes la manière
de dépenser et en terme quantitatif dans
une démocratie celui qui gagne gagne
monsieur
trudau je vais finir ma phrase madame
j'ai confiance je fais confiance au
Québécois les règles normales de la
démocratie peuvent s'appliquer
Constitution pour changer la
constitution Monsieur trudau Madame un
instant on va reprendre notre souffle un
petit peu monsieur avait demandé la
parole j'ai pris des positions sur
toutes ces questions il y a 20 ans
pendant et
après la la le référendire précédent et
depuis depuis cette époque 20 ans les
Québécois sont clair ils ne veulent pas
d'autres référendum je n'ai pas
intention de rouvrir ces débats ici le V
le vrai débat aujourd'hui est sur
l'économie sur nos valeurs sur notre
sécurité le choix entre des déficits
permanents des hausses de taxes d'impôt
et la et la perte d'emploi ou des
baisses de taxes d'impôt des budgets
équilibré et la création d'emploi en
parlant d'équilibre d'équilibre du temps
monsieur trouddeau d'abord monsieur du
ensuite Monsieur trouau Madame aprs
monsieur mulker reconnaît très bien que
pour enlever le mot nouveau de la
constitution du Nouveau Parti
démocratique parce ça fait 60 ans que
sont sont là euh il faudrait une
majorité plus qu'une simple majorité
pour changer leur constitution or pour
déchirer en deux la Constitution du
Canada il prétend qu'un seul vote serait
assez la Cour suprême a dit très
clairement unanimement que ça prenait
plus que ça il ce serait à déterminer
lors d'un prochain référendum pour moi
que Monsieur mulker ait soulevé cette
questionl en français à la
Saint-Jean-Baptiste et à bien d'autres
moments mais n'en parle pas en anglais
c'est un réel problème pour quelqu'un
qui vere premier minist don
l'interpellation direct 15 15 secondes
monsieur mul avant de la déclaration de
ch qui est écrite en anglais et en
français précise notre position làdessus
ça jamais vérifié et j'ai dit la même
chose dans toutes les interview que j'ai
donné depuis les 4 années que je suis là
madame du sa on est conséquent et on est
le Nouveau Parti démocratique madame
passent de parler mais j'avais dit
Monsieur avant monsieur dit qu'il
respecterait les lois du Québec mais en
95 le fédéral n'a pas respecté les
limites de dépensesétais C vous étiez à
l'Assemblée nationale et vous avez
participé au camp d'union et le camp
d'union avait des une limite de
financement le fédéral ne l'a pas
respecté la Cour suprême a décidé que le
fédéral le fédéral n'avait pas obéi au
aux loi du Québec est-ce que vous croyez
que le fédéral doit se soumettre aux
lois du Québec aux loi référendire oui
ou non put pas de faute qui n'est pas la
mienne j'étais un démocrate dans cette
élection là j'étais un député à
l'Assemblée nationale du Québec je me
suis battu loyalement vous avez
participé au line là qui était financé
par le fédéral et ça ça dépassa les
limites de fin che moi a
personneanero ce soit arrêtez de des
choses
sont répondez donc la question est-ce
que vous selon vous le
fédér est-ce que le fédéral est-ce que
le fédéral doit respecter la loi
référendaire du Québec oui ou non c'est
clair tout ça par écrit contrairement
aux
autres
dans
est-ceon est-ce qu'on veut vraiment un
parlement qui RTE sur ces
questions l'économie c'est la priorité
des Canadiens l'économie la
sécurité par ver c'est clair nous
respectons le principe
d'autodétermination des peuples les
peuples de Québec les peuples de
Première nation c'est un question une
question de respect mais nous devons
travailler ensemble pour un grand projet
société pour éliminer les débats sur ce
gouvernement est reconnaître la nation
québécoise sans rouvrir un tel débat ce
n'est pas ou mais quand vous avez déjà
fait une loi dans l'opposition disant
que c'était 50 % dites pas le contraire
Monsieur Merci monsieur multaire alors
ce thème de la gouvernance de la
démocratie l'tion va se clore sur cette
question à vous C en ayant chacun 25
secondes pour répondre et c'est Patrice
qui vous la pose monsieur un peu vous
venez de parler de sécurité il y a eu ce
débat on assé ce débat au Canada sur le
projet de loi qui est maintenant une loi
C51 question à tous les chefs et essayer
de parler pour que je vous en prie que
les gens vous
comprennent sur cette question là qui
est importante est-ce que le prix à
payer pour vivre en sécurité c'est de
donner encore et toujours plus de
pouvoir à la police autrement dit je
vous demande l'équilibre entre la
sécurité et les droits monsieur Harper
c'est nécessaire de de d'avoir la
sécurité et la protection de nos droits
et nos libertés nous faisons les deux et
c'est important les deux les deux se
renforce et dans not projet de loi on
don plus de ressources et des pouvoirs
normau pour des agences de sécurité de
police maintenant il y a une vraie
menace dans le monde le terrorisme
djihadiste international on doit se se
on doit être contre ça et on doit
protéger nos libertés c'est ce que nous
on fait madame c'est clair que cette loi
7 51 est les plus dangereuse loi dans
l'histoire du Canada cette loi rend les
Canadiens moins libre et en même temps
rend le Canada moins sécuritaire c'est
clair que cette loi je vous demander de
déposer votre Tex de loi madame je crois
que on do pas afficher DEC c'est clair
que cette loi est vraiment dangereuse et
c'est comme nous avions augmenté les
risques de collision sans mettre en
place un système de feu de signalisation
madame monsieur truddeau monsieur
monsieur Harper pense qu'on n pas besoin
de rien faire de plus pour protéger nos
libertés monsieur mulkerire pense qu'on
ne doit rien faire de plus pour protéger
notre sécurité le Parti libéral veut
faire les deux en même temps c'est pour
ça nous proposons un comité de
parlementaire pour surveiller toutes nos
institutions de de de police et de de
sécurité nationale c'est cet équilibre
là que le Parti libéral a toujours su
faire et qui va continuer de faire
monsieur du oui cette loi ne respecte
pas le nécessaire équilibre entre
liberté et sécurité c'est ce qu'il faut
faire dans notre société sinon on fait
le jeu des fanatiques cela étant dit il
aurait fallu renforcer les pouvoirs du
comité de surveillance du service de
renseignement canadien et sur ça je
rappelle que les conservateurs la NPD et
les libéraux ont tous appuyé la
nomination d'Arthur porter au comité de
surveillance des services de
renseignement du Canada alors j'aimerais
qu' qu'il réponde à cela madame monsieur
mulker pour je suis d'accord avec Madame
mais cette loi constitue une attaque en
règle contre les droits et libertés de
l'ensemble des Canadiens quand nous on a
commencé avec notre opposition il y
avait plus de 80 % des Canadiens qui
étaient en faveur de la loi mais sur une
question de principe on s'est tenu
debout tout comme le NPD était le seul à
se tenir debout contre la loi sur les
mesure de guerre de Pierre Trudeau qui a
mis des centaines de Québécois en prison
sans procès on va abroger purement et
simple simplement la loi merci merci
nous passons maintenant au 4e thème du
débat l'environnement le monde entier
est convié à Paris au mois de décembre
pour la grande conférence sur le climat
considérée par plusieurs comme la
rencontre de la dernière chance vous
savez on compte par millions les
déplacés les réfugiés climatiques les
cris d'alarme des scientifiques mais
aussi de grandes organisations
international se font de plus en plus
entendre même le pape françois s'en mêle
de ce débat le temps presse la question
s'adresse à Monsieur Steven un pe il
bois vert pose la première question le
Canada est considéré par plusieurs comme
un cancre dans la lutte au changement
climatique même le secrétaire général
des Nations Unies a dit que le pays
manque d'ambition dans ses cibles
aujourd'hui aux États-Unis le pape dit
qu'il considérait que c'était un enjeu
moral
urgent nos cibles de réduction de gaz à
effet de ser ne sont pas la moitié de
celle de l'Europe monsieur Harper vous
serez pas gêné un peu en arrivant à la
conférence de Paris sur le climat merci
pour la question pour la toute première
fois sur notre gouvernement dans une
période de croissance économique on a
réduit les émissions de gaz effet de
serre c'est la première fois on a fait
ça on a fait ça en poursuivant un
système de réglementation en évitant des
taxes sur la carbone pour les
consommateurs il y a en en 2006 nous
avons quand nous sommes arrivés au
pouvoir nous avons proposé qu'on a
besoin de nouvell entente internationale
qui inclu tous les grands émetteurs
c'était une idée radicale dans cette
époque maintenant c'est accepté par tous
nos partenaires et nos cibles sont très
proches aux autres partenaires et je
suis très optimiste qu'on va avoir une
telle entente à Paris cette année et
nous travaillons pour faire ça première
rposte à Monsieur mulker monsieur Harper
a déposé des documents au Nations Unies
qui démontre que la seule et unique
raison de cette réduction parce qu'on
avait perdu 400000 emplois dans le
secteur manufacturer une usine ferm ça
met pas beaucoup de GS quand j'étais le
ministre de l'Environnement ici au
Québec j'avais un plan clair chaque
année que j'étais ministre j'ai réduit
les gaz effet de ser c'était une
priorité il faut en faire une priorité
il y a aucun autre sujet plus important
pour le prochain Premier ministre que de
s'assurer qu'on travail sur les
changements climatiques et pour réduire
les gaz à effet de S c'est un bilan dont
je suis faire et au fédéral je vais
amener une Loi sur le développement
durable comme celle que j'ai amené au
Québec où on est allé même jusqu'à
changer la la charte des lois pour
inclure le droit de vivre dans un
environnement sain madame oui je vais
participer au négociation changement
climatique il y a beaucoup beaucoup
années et c'est clair que quand je
regarde le le le la délégation de Canada
dans ses négociations avec les
instructions de vous-même monsieur
Harper le but de notre délégation c'est
de saboter les conférences sur le
changement climatique nous c'est c'est
pour ça que nous avons perdu notre
réputation mondiale c'est clair que en
doit préparer pour les négociations à
Paris et c'est pas possible si vous
restez comme premier ministre monsieur
toudau ça fait 10 ans que monsieur
Harper fait rien sur l'environnement on
sa très très bien heureusement enttemps
les provinces sont pris de l'avance le
Québec l'Ontario la Colombie Britannique
et même l'Alberta sont all d'avant pour
mettre un prix sur le carbone nous avons
besoin de travailler avec les provinces
pour présenter un front commun à à à
Paris en décembre en fin novembre pour
démontrer que le Canada va faire sa part
pour réduire les gaz à effet de serre et
reprendre sa place de respect face à la
planète
monsieur on réduit les émissions de gaz
effet de ser pour donner un exemple on a
créé des une réglement système de
réglementation pour des centrales
d'électricité qui est en train
d'éliminer les centrales du charbon au
Canada nous c'est c'est le plus
la plus grande source des émissions de
gaz effet de ser dans le monde et nous
nous serons le première le premier pays
d'éliminer ce ce genre des émissions je
pense que Monsieur har son vin est
pitoyable sur l'environnement et même le
fond énergie propre là le Québec a reçu
11 millions che le Canada 120 millions
et Monsieur Molka partage le même le
même avis sur le fond d'énergie propre
or c'est pas c'est pas le principe du
pollueur payeur c'est pollueur payé et
moi ce qui me surprend par ailleurs
c'est que Monsieur M et tr sont contre
le nor Gateway contre le Keystone Excel
mais ils sont en faveur d'nière JS qui
va traverser 600 nos rivière et le
fleuve Saint-Laurent sont en faveur du
projet bune à nouveau brunwick où il va
y avoir 240 trains par jour de du type
de ceux qui sont passés à l'AC mgantique
al je comprends pas comment ils peuvent
être contre de tel projet dans l'Ouest
mais pour au Québec monsieur ducep le
Parti libéral est très clair nous nous
devons de rendre nos rources vers les
marchés mais ça se fait de façon en
respectant les communautés ça doit se
faire avec les partenariats avec les
Premières nations ça se ça doit se faire
dans le la conformité environnementale
et scientifique or nous avons besoin de
complètement refaire le processus par
lequel s'est évalué j'ai été très clair
depuis le début à ce niveau-là et je
vais continuer de dire que nous allons
réformer le processus d'évaluation
environnementale pour qu'on puisse
rendre nos ressources vers les marchés
sans mettre au péril les générations
futur mais monsieur monsieur Harper a
dit qu'il a mettre sur pied un système
pour réduire le gar effet de effet de
ser c'est pas vrai il a annulé le
programme et politique pour Duer les
gazet de ser en même temps il a augmenté
les émissions de sable biur et c'est le
Parti vert aussi c'est que contre tous
les piplin qui va transpor le produit de
fossil but ce n'est pas bon pour
l'économie ni pour l'environnement et
c'est contre les but de
g je pe une autre façon par laquelle on
réduit les émissions de gaz effet de ser
on investit chaque année not arrivé en
fonction plus de milliard de dans le
développement de l'énergie propre de
nouvelles technologies il compris 350
millions de dollars pour le programme du
Québec et on va continuer ces
investissements parce qu'on a un budget
équilibré ces investissement son
garantie
monsieur le Canada est le seul pays P au
monde à s'être retiré du protocole de
Kyoto et c'est la faute de monsieur
Harper ça c'est son bilan les libéraux
ont signé Kyoto mais comedy Goldenberg
l'ancien chef de cabinet de jeanchrétien
l' admis il n'avait aucun plan pour
rencontrer des objectif en fait sous les
libéraux on a eu un des pires bilan au
monde je pense qu'il y avait juste le
Kazakhstan qui était pire ça c'est le
bilan des libéraux moi je vais prendre
cette responsabilité très au sérieux je
vais m'assurer que les Canadiens
puissent tablir sur nous pour rencontrer
cette obligation pérenne monsieur trudau
monsieur monsieur monsieur mulker parle
que de d'avoir été ministre de
l'Environnement au Québec mais il
comprend pas que son approche pour
réduire les gaz à effet de serre est
complètement centralisatrice il veut
imposer d'Awa un système de bourse de
carbone qui va pénaliser la Colombie
Britannique qui est allée de l'avant
avec une taxe sur le carbone et qui va
imposer son système d'Otawa sur Québec
et Ontario c'est vous avez pas mis de
plan vous avez rien expliqué de votre
plan vous êtes en train d'être
centralisateur et c'est vraiment
désolant pour leébec mon monsieur
déclaré au débat en anglais que nergs un
WIN WIN WIN et au Québec il veulent nous
faire croire qu' sont pas tout à fait
pour je prends des citations en 2010
Thomas molker disait en français nous
savons qu'il est impossible de continuer
l'exploitation des sablesumineux sans
gravement affecter la santé des êtres
humains et sans détruire à tout jamais
d'important écosystèm Thomas Tom en
anglais en 2012 vous ne m'entendrez
jamais par contre le développement des
saumineux j'aimerais savoir si Tom parle
à th temps unutre et quelle est la
véritable position vous êtes interpellé
15 secondes avant de Monsieur Je
n'approuverai jamais Energ est avec le
système baclé de monsieur Harper il y a
pas de possibilité d'approuver quoi que
ce soit il a éviciré un ensemble de lois
environnementales il y a plus de
processus complet et crédiible au Canada
et encore une fois c'est la faute de St
l'ancien gouvernement a signé l'accord
signé le Protocole de Kyoto et en R les
les cibles par 30 % ce n'est pas juste
d'exposer les contribuables du Canada à
des peines pour ça on poursuit sur ce
même thème prochaine question Patrice
ouais ben c'est directement en ligne
avec ce que vous venez de discuter
depuis la tragédie de l'ct mégantique
c'est une évidence les gens sont très
sensibles à la question du transport du
pétrole monsieur mulkerer Mons DUP vient
de vous accuser de ne pas avoir été tout
à fait clair euh je vous donne
l'occasion et l'occasion à tous les
chefs et je vais la formuler comme ça
est-ce que vous préférez les pipelines
ou les trains avec un processus complet
crédible d'évaluation environnementale
on va pouvoir inclure toutes les
questions de sécurité mais surtout
inclure les changements climatiques et
les gaz à effet ça a jamais été fait et
quand nous on va faire des règles ça va
être complet crédible inclure les gaz
effet de C sur le transport sur la
sécurité en général c'est une des
principales responsabilités de tout
gouvernement se protéger le public avec
monsieur Harper il a évacué les lois il
laisse les compagnies ferroviaires
s'inspecter elle-même mais en plus il
laisse les compagnies qui font la
production alimentaire s'inspecter
elle-même c'est pour ça qu'on a eu les
deux PL importantes rappel de viande
avarié de l'histoire du Canada il faut
que le gouvernement assume le rôle de
protection du public le débat s'ouvre à
5 monsieur vous avez ét interpellé par
Monsieur M je pense que le bilan des
pipelines son très sécuritaires mais
avant approuvé un piplin le gouvernement
a un processus indépendant scientifique
et et on on poursuit ses recommandations
par exemple pour le Northern Gateway le
comité indépendant a recommandé 200
conditions on a mis en vigueur ces
conditions pour l'approvation c'est
nécessaire d'avoir des processus
indépendants avec une date limite de 2
ans c'est 2 ans et ce sont c'est
nécessaire de suivre les évaluations
scientifiques et pas seulement des
opinions des politiciersad c'est clair
que le problème ce n'est pas les
pipelines ou les trains le problème
c'est le produit et quand on a un
stratégie économique où c'est le but
c'est l'export de produits fossils bruts
les produits de sable binux brut sont
plus dangereux pour pour transport un
seul accident
pétrolier va contaminer tous les cours
cours d'eau et c'est pour Quebec c'est
très important de protéger le fleuve
Saint-Laurent ce n'est pas une autoroute
de
pétrole monsieur Herp à démontrer depuis
10 ans qu'il ne comprend pas qu'au 21e
siècle l'économie et l'environnement ça
va ensemble on ne peut pas développer
des emplois ou développer nos ressources
ou les les rendre au marché si on n'est
pas en train de s'occuper de
l'environnement si on est en train de
marginaliser comme il l' fait le
processus d'évaluation les partenariats
avec les communautés premières nation
les les partenariats avec les
communautés touché par ces projets nous
avons besoin de restaurer la confiance
dans un gouvernement qui sera arbitre et
non cheerleader pour pour pour les
projets de pipeline et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que monsieur Harper a
tellement de misère à avoir cette
confiance publique nécessaire pour
développer nos ressources et créer des
emplois mon c'est intéressant de
d'entendre les les perspectives de de
ces parti très négatives envers le
secteur énergétique et les pipelin c'est
tout à fait le contraire quand on a fait
le débat à cargar pour nous on encourage
les investissements dans le secteur
énergétique mais pour des projets avant
de l'approvation on doit avoir
évaluation scientifique qu'onit monsieur
la question c'est à savoir des des
pipelines ou Bonom des trains je vous
dirais nerg là ça diminue pas le
transport ferroviaire puisque ce pétrole
là ni consommé ni raffiné au Québec ça
va continuer à augmenter et il y avait
500 vagons en 2009 de du genre de celui
à l'AC mégratique en 2013 460000 hein
c'est ça la réalité al moi la question
que je pose aux autres chefs c'est
est-ce qu' serait pas normal que ce qui
pare sur le territoire du Québec soit
décidé par l'assemblée national du
Québec en vertu des recommandations du
BAP et non pas par l'Office national
d'énergie à Calgary contrôlé par les
pétrolières et que ça soit décidé par
est-ce que c'est pas aux Québécois au
québécoises de décider ce qui va passer
sur leur territoire et non pas
surommandation de c'est la même question
pour les gens de Colombie Britannique
nous avons la même question pourquoi le
gouvernement fédéral on exig que N accep
P Kinder Morgan
etdge parce que le peuple de col
britannique sont en solidarité avec les
peuples de Québec et dit non au Pipin
avec les produits
bruts monsieur TR la réalité c'est qu'on
a besoin de reconnaître que le Canada a
besoin d'une stratégie énergétique a
besoin de de coordonner avec les
provinces pour montrer du leadership
pour démontrer qu'on peut créer des
emplois partout de la croissance
économique mais de pas mettre en danger
notre environnement monsieur Harper a
complètement failli je comprends que les
gens sont inquiets à ce niveau-là mais
nous nous devons le faire ensemble au
Québec a décidé monsieur Harper l'idée
de l'énergie est c'est de remplasser le
pétrole étrangère avec le pétrole
canadien de de faire son développement
ici au Canada et d'assurer
l'approvisionnement pour tous
les on aura une évaluation scientifique
avant de
décider ni consommé ni raffiné au
Québec
raffinerie Canada d'Atlantique nous
n'avons pas un réfinerie qui a
capabilité de de raffiner le produit
brut du B menu ça c'est le problème
c'est pour
on ça c'est la solution
monsieur monsieur Harper parle de
création d'emploi l'oloduc Keystone exel
va exporter 40000 emplois vers les
États-Unis et c'est pas mon chiffre
c'est son chiffre c'est le chiffre qui
l' utilisé pour vendre ce projet là aux
Américains monsieur Harper et Monsieur
Trudeau veulent exporter à l'état brut
sans valeur ajoutée nos richesses
naturelles au cours des 15 dernières 15
prochaines années il va se dépenser à
travers le monde 5000 milliards en
énergie propre et renouvelable on n même
pas dans le marché parce que eux ils y
croivent pas nous on va en faire une
priorité mais on va aussi s'assurer
d'ajouter de la valeur à nos richesses
naturelles et pas les exporter
à chef national ne comprend pas que des
exportations créent des emplois à deux
côtés deux côtés de fronèr dans les deux
pays c'est la raison pour laqu on
encourage les exportations mais voilà l'
éologie protectionniste
NPD CR au
Canada je crer au Canada ses emplois
monsur on parle de pétrole aujourd'hui
mais on sait que quand on parle des
années à venir il va avoir énormément de
préoccupation par rapport à l'eau et on
parle de l'exportation or monsieur
mulker qui aime parler du fait qu'il
était ministre de l'Environnement ici au
Québec propos des exportations en vraat
de notre eau vers les États-Unis alors
il faudrait
il reste temps 15 secondes
pouraculairement factice et ça encore
une
foisé
rououou les restrictions les plus
sévères d'Amérique du Nord le
résultatri vous comprenez pas qu'il faut
avoir des débats parfois parce que vous
quelqu'un doit vous
écrire monsieur s'il vous plaît monsieur
trudau il continue de de de dire qu'il
le pas fait on l' sur vidéo
paration sévè en Amérique du Nord
monsieur TR dites pas n'importe quoi sur
le thème de l'environnement la même
question C chefs la première Ros tiant
monsieur DUP il bois ver le transport
est responsable de environ la moitié des
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
plusieurs Canadiens voudraient rouler
dans une voiture verte
mais sont souvent hors de prix est-ce
que c'est une bonne idée pour le
gouvernement de subventionner ces
véhicules là exactement la proposition
que nous avons faite Québec donne déjà
des crédits d'impôt pour l'achat d'une
voiture électrique au hybride Otawa
devra faire la même chose accorder des
crédits d'impôt pour les voitures
hybrides ou électriques et de cette
façonlà on réduirait effectivement les
gaz effet ser c'est au Québec qui a le
plus d'auto électrique monsieur Harper
comme je viens de dire le fééral
investit un milliard dellar chaque année
pour développer les nouvelles
technologie la technologies vertes c'est
une c'est un bon investissement pour le
système de transport poursuivant un
système de réglementation en
collaboration avec les États-Unis pour
ce secteur et ça va continuer à réduire
les émissions de gaz effet de serre
madame peut-être ce n'est pas un très
bonne idée de vous avez prêté 500
millions de dollars à Volkswagen en
avril mais quand même nous sommes som au
début d'une révolution économique une
révolution technologique vers une
nouvelle économie vert actuellement nous
avons créé déjà plus d'emplois dans les
technologies propre que dans le sable
Bux déjà Monsieur M c'est une occasion
enord pour le Québec de participer à ça
nous avons déjà de plus grande la plus
grande proportion d'énergie propre et
renouvelable de toute autre juridiction
en Amérique du Nord profitons-en on a
des technologies de point on peut
développer des véhicules électriques ici
il faut en faire une priorité mais il
faut aussi croire un rôle positif pour
le gouvernement monsieur Harper n'y
croit pas on sait qu'il y a un énorme
dépense qui va se faire à travers le
monde là-dedans nous on va être à
l'avantpl un champion pour le secteur de
fabrication monsieur trudau le Parti
libéral du Canada propose des
investissements records dans des
infrastructures vertes de 20 milliards
de dollars sur 10 ans on a aussi des
investissements dans l'économie verte
dans la recherche dans l'augmentation de
notre capacité de compétitionner de
façon propre partout dans le monde dans
notre développement c'est ce que le
Parti libéral a un plan pour faire les
autres continuent juste d'en parler nous
on va agir immédiatement merci nous
passons maintenant au 5e et dernier
thème de la soirée le Canada dans le
monde jamais peut-être depuis la deuxème
Guerre mondiale les conflits dans le
monde et les crises humanitaires n'ont à
ce point mis à l'épreuve la stabilité du
monde et chaque pays doit faire face à
de très lourdes responsabilités
qu'avez-vous à proposer quels sont vos
choix la question s'adresse à Monsieur
troudeau et c'est Pat trce qui la pause
merci anne-emarie le Canada et c'était
un gouvernement libéral s'est engagé en
Afghanistan avec un lourd sacrifice en
vie humaines et en blessé inutile de le
souligner on le sait tous monsieur
Trudeau comme monsieur mulker vous
pensez qu'il faut cesser les
bombardements contre le groupe armélam
en Irak et en Syrie question que
j'espère la plus simple possible même si
c'est un problème complexe si on refuse
de se battre contre les horreurs de
l'État islamique contre quoi et contre
qui le Canada ira se battre le Parti
libéral est très clair le Canada a un
rôle important à jouer dans la lutte
contre l'État islamique il compris un
rôle militaire nous croyons que comme on
a fait en Afghanistan nous pouvons faire
de la formation sur le terrain avec nos
militaires des forces armées locales on
le sait depuis depuis bien des années
que quand on envoie des troupes ou unee
intervention occidentale dans cette
régionlà ça finit toujours par causer
autant de troubles sinon plus que ça
règle c'est pour ça que le Canada se
devrait d'aider de former les les armées
locaux arrêter le bombardement à faire
beaucoup plus au niveau humanitaire et
surtout réfugiés c'est pour ça que ça
fait 6 mois que le Parti libéral demande
au gouvernement d'amener immédiatement
25000 réfugiés syriens le Canada a
toujours été un pays engagé dans le
monde on a perdu beaucoup de plumes
depuis 10 ans de monsieur Harper nous
devons reprendre notre place pour avoir
un impact positif dans la lutte pour la
sécurité et pour aider les gens dans la
détresse première rposte monsieur mais
bien sûr qu'il faut donner la la
priorité à l'aide humanitaire cependant
il arrive des moments dans l'histoire où
il faut intervenir
militairement j'ai rencontré je ne sais
combien de gens qui ont proché au Canada
de ne pas et à beaucoup d'autres pays de
pas être intervenu au Rwanda hein et on
a on en a tiré la leçon le Canada est
intervenu au Kosovo avec des frappes
militaires rappelons-le parce qu'il y
avait un génocide qui se produisait et
on a accueillli des covirs ici 6000 en
quelques semaines là on pourrait
accueillir très rapidement les 10000
Syriens non'ont pas attendre 2018 mais
on peut pas faire d'aide humanitaire
conog est à la porte de l'État islamique
dire nous venons de apporter de l'aide
humanitaire les principales victimes de
l'État islamique de l'Armée islamique ce
sont les musulmanes des femmes des
fillettes on peut pas laisser des crimes
contre l'humanité se perpétuer sous
prétexte qu' on n'intervient pas
militairement on poursuiv un politique
équilibré pour les réfugiés pour l'aide
humanitaire pour les millions qui
restent dans la région et surtout aussi
la mission militaire contre le
soi-dissant état islamique il y a une
soixantaine de pays qui sont impliqués
dans cette mission c'est ce groupe a
l'intention d'utiliser la Syrie et
l'Irak comme une base pour des
opérations terroristes contre le monde y
compris le Canada et c'est une c'est une
grande menace à notre pays c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes là avec
nos alliés c'est nécessaire de continuer
la pression contre ce groupe terroriste
madame c'est nécessaire c'est absolument
nécessaire de faire les choses qui sont
utiles et c'est inutile d'avoir les
bombardement contre l'État islamique ce
n'est pas la guerre civile ce n'est pas
causé par État islamique et la crise
humanitaire est causé par le dictateur
Bachar al-Assad la guerre civile est
causée par le dictateur Bachar alAssad
avec son bélin meutrié il a tué h fois
plus des gens que l'État islamique c'est
dans cette guerre civile il y a les
groupes horrifiques il y a état
islamique qui était contre Bashar
al-Assad aussi c contre Bashar al-Assad
elle nous contre Bachar alAssad et avec
Bachar alAssad le Hezbollah il n'y a pas
un groupe là pour donner l'appu c'est
seulement nécessaire de travailler pour
la paix et pour arrêter le financement
de l'État islamique monsieur MKA oui le
Canada peut jouer un rôle il faut couper
les livres à la source arrêter que
l'argent s'y rende arrêter que les armes
s'y rendent et s'assurer que les
combattants étrangers s'y rendent pas
mais pour se faire il faudrait que le
Canada signe le traité international sur
le trafic d'armes nous sommes le seul
membre de longtemp à ne pas avoir signé
pour ce qui est du projet de loi c'est51
totalement silencieux sur la
radicalisation qui est une source
justement de ces combattants étrangers
nous sommes opposés à un rôle de combat
actuel en Irak et en Syrie et on le dit
clairement pas Mo pas de demi-mesure
nous sommes plutôt d'accord avec les
vers sur cette questionl on participera
pas à cette guerreci monsieur ce n'est
pas nécessaire de choisir dire entre
l'aide humanitaire et la mission
militaire on on on doit faire les deux
et on on fait les deux c'est la même
chose avec la sécurité et les libertés
ce n'est pas nécessaire de choisir on
doit faire les deux dans ce monde
dangereux ce que nous avons fait
monsieur trudau monsieur Harper toujours
parler de ça mais la réalité c'est queil
est pas en train d'investir comme il
faut dans nos forces armées il est pas
en train d'obtenir les les les
équipements nécessaires il est pas en
train de s'occuper de nos anciens
combattants quand ils reviennent et il
n'est pas en train de faire l'aide
humanitaire ni l'aide aux réfugiés qu'on
devrait avoir le Canada fut jadis un
pays respecté dans le monde pour ses
intervention pour son engagement dans le
monde et depuis 10 ans avec monsieur
Harper on s'est retiré on est devenu
plus mesquin moins canadien à l'échelle
internationale il faut que ça change
c'est ridicule on rebattit les forces
armées après la décenniees de Nour
décrit forcesita que nous on dépensé par
capit merc
dans le pour question de réfugi on a
déjà dit plus de rfugiés plus vite mais
en en protégeant toujours notre sécurité
et en assurer la sélection des réfugiés
les plus vérables par notre pays mais
mais il faudra être conséquent
monsieurper quand on se bat contre
l'État islamique le soit-disant état
islamique il faut savoir que l'idéologie
qui est pré là été financé est promu par
l'Arabie Saoudite et on vend des
milliards pour des milliards d'armes à
l'Arabie Saoudite est-ce qu'il serait
pas cohérent de dire ça suffit entre
autres en pensant seulement à rarif
Badaoui de dire ça suffit on ce la vente
d'armes à l'Arabie Saoudite ça sera
conséquent que la position que l'on a
dans cette lutte contre l'État islamique
l'Armée islamique comme la Suède l'a
fait par exemple c'est nécessaire c'est
nécessaire aussi de contrer le
financement de l'État islamique et euh
président et les autres alliés travaill
sur ça comme nous travaillons sur la
Radical radicalisation le Canada a le le
programme
d'antiradicalisation et d'intégration
qui a la plus grand réussit tout
monde la vente d'armes à l'Arabie
Saoudite est-ce qu'on devrait pas cesser
ça c'est la question est claire je vous
demande pas de me conter toutes sortes
d'histoirees question là précise est-ce
qu'on devrait pas cesser de des on a
compris votre question monsieur secondes
monsieur nous nous avons le plus grand
contrat d'exportation dans dans
l'histoire au Canada nos
alliés allons allons faire la même chose
ce n'est pas un appui pour l'État
islamique c'est un appui pour un allié
et pour not l'arabbie Saoudite est un
beau allié très bien j'en prends note on
a un gouvernement qui continue de parler
de nos forces armées de de vouloir
utiliser les forces armé comme appui
pour son agenda de peur et de sécurité
mais il ne donne pas les les les outils
nécessaires nous proposons d'annuler les
F35 d'investir dans la marine canadienne
et de s'occuper de nos anciens
combattants comme eux ils n'ont pas fait
depuis 10
ansad oui monsieur Harper a fait les
choses dans les changements de lois pour
l'immigration et réfugiés qui rendent le
système absolument comme un cauchemar
c'est impossible d'aider les réfugiés
maintenant au contraire dans le temps
passer pour aider les peuples de Vietnam
on doit changer les lois et aussi
garantir la sécurité
monsur monsur avant de s'engager à
mettre nos militaires en danger il faut
avoir un un mandat clair une stratégie
de sortie être à la hauteur des risques
encourux par nos militaires et par leurs
famillees j'aiécouté monsieur Trudeau
tout à l'heure parler du fait qu'il faut
arrêter la politique de peur de monsieur
Harper il a voté pour le projet de loi
51 parce qu'il avait peur de monsieur
Harper au contraire monsieur question de
relance si vous voulez bien question de
rel bois vert et vous allez l'occasion
de continuer sur ce thème on fait face
euh ces jours-ci à la plus grande crise
de réfugiés depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale en Europe monsieur Harper
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à l'ancien
chef d'état-major de l'armée canadienne
Rick Hillier selon qui la question de la
sécurité ce n'est qu'un prétexte que
vous utilisez pour ne pas agir que le
Canada n'en fait pas assez et qu'on
pourrait même aller jusqu'à accueillir
50000 réfugiés d'ici la fin de l'année
il quand on a quand on a vu le photos de
ce garçon sur la plage tout le monde a
été touché par ça je me souviens de mon
fils Benjamin à même
âge en courant sur la plage on est tous
touchés par ça mais on doit on doit
répondre d'une façon généreuse et
responsable le avance même avant c'est
mon chef j'ai déjà annoncé plus de
réfugiés que nous accepterons de cette
région j'ai annoncé maintenant un
système plus vite j'ai annoncé l'aide
humanitaire un fond de un fond de
contrepartie pour la région pour
encourager les dents en même temps on
doit ce n'est pas le temps de juste
ouvrir les les vines ce n'est pas
responsable on doit en drit maintenir
notre système de sélection de sélection
des groupes prioritaires et d'assurer
notre sécurité ça fait des années qu'on
est à la chambre de commune à regarder
monsieur Harper dire qu'il est en train
d'aider les réfugiés mais de ne rien
faire il rate toutes les cibles même
très modestes qu'ils ont mis de l'avant
il est temps que le Canada redevienne un
pays qui accueille les gens en détresse
on a toujours su équilibrer la sécurité
avec cette générosité ça a jamais été
question il utilise comme distraction
comme il comme monsieur boivt l'a
souligné et il continue de de
d'esquisser la question de pourquoi le
Canada n'est pas en train d'être le pays
que les gens à travers le monde ont
toujours vu le Canada comme étant
Monsieur D oui moi je crois qu'on
devrait s'inspirer de ce qui s'est passé
au Kosovo euh on est intervenu
militairement mais on est intervenu pour
accueillir ici les cosovares très
rapidement en peu de semaines en en le
faisant avec la Croix-Rouge en le
faisant avec les provinces les
représentants de chacune des provinces
ministre de l'Immigration là où il y en
a ont rencontré le fédéral ont établi
des cibles parce que ces gens-là vont
vivre quelque part dans les provinces
dans les municipalités les provinces
sont prêtes les municipalités sont
prêtes la quix rouge est prête c'est le
fédéral qui est pas prêt monsieur
madameôt oui oui c'est c'est vrai c'est
clair que le gouvernement fédéral a n'a
pas réussi dans leur engagement pour
l'acceptance de 10000 réfugiés c'est
clair que le suppus budgétaire est
réalisé de l'année passée avec les
décisions d'arrêter les dépenses presque
9 milliards de dépenses sinclut les
dépenses c'est que c'est accepté dans le
budget ils ont arrêté les dépenses pour
pour pour aider les réfugiés et aussi
pour les communauté autochton et aussi
pour les investissements euh des
infrastructures réplique de Monsieur
parant franchement du Bénin nous avons
accueilli un quart de million de
réfugiés depuis notre arrivée en
fonction c'est un des programmes le plus
généreux du monde on accepte des
réfugiés de de tous les coins du monde y
compris déjà 23 m000 de de la Syrie de
l'IRAC de la région mais ce n'est pas
responsable juste de dire qu'on va qu'on
va ouvrir les les les vin ce n'est pas
une approche responsable on a une
approche généreuse équilibrée mais aussi
responsable et réfléchi monsieur MCL ça
a été démenti et prouvé que c'est
complètement faux les chiffres que
monsieur Harper est en train de nous
mettre ici ce soir ce petit garçonl il
avait un nom il s'appelait Allan kururdy
sa famille avait essayé à travers un de
nos députés de commencer le processus et
tout ça ça été donné au ministre
Alexander après coup évidemment ils ont
essayé de faire des nuances mais la
réalité c'est que le ministre Alexandre
ne fait rien il demandait à nos députés
d'apporter ça plutôt que de soulever ça
à la période des questions on a essayé
la réalité madame dusau c'est que Chris
Alexander ne dit pas la vérité aux
journalistes ne dit pas la vérité aux
Canadiens depuis le début de ça les
nations- Unies ont demandé au Canada
d'accepter 9000 d'ici Noël il faut le
faire les Nations Unies nous ont demandé
d'ammener 46000 au cours des quatre
prochaines années nous allons le faire
cette histoired est tout à fait fausse
et c'est déjà prouvé un DP devrait
devrait sexcus qui devz excus c'est vous
qui devriez vous excuser
monsieur nous avons longtemps proposé
d'amener 25000 réfugiés syriens
immédiatement oui en s'occupant de la
sécurité mais en aussi en sachant que
c'est comme ça que le Canada a été bâti
que ce soit les Vietnamiens venus à à la
fin de la guerre du Vietnam où on en a
accepté presque 60000 ça a eu un impact
extrêmement positif et on voit souvent
ça ici à Montréal avec bien des
communautés on a besoin d'être une fois
de plus le pays généreux qu'on a été or
monsieur Harper quand les réfugiés
arrivent il leur enlève leur système de
santé il leur enlève la capacité de
d'élever bien leurs enfants en sécurité
et en santé c'est pas ça la générosité
qu'on doit avoir en tant que
payss ce n'est pas ce n'est pas vrai on
a un système de santé pour nos réfugiés
pour nos nouveaux immigrants mais quon
on on a été rejeté par le système parce
qu'on a fait une prétension fausse c'est
là où on coupe le système de santé on ne
doit pas don un système de santé
meilleur
pour plus personne qui vous monsieur
Harper de toute façon monsieur moi moi
j'ai pe posé au tout début de de cette
crise de dire qu'il ne faut pas en faire
une question partisane de réunir les
gens de tous les partis de travailler en
concert avec la société civile je
parlais de la quix rouge de travailler
avec les provinces avec les
municipalités c'est ça qu'il faut faire
on l'a fait dans le cas du Kosovo avec
succès avec succès on a évité un
génocide là-bas il y a des crimes contre
l'humanité ce sont les femmes les
musulmanes qui sont en sont les
premières victimes je pense monsieur
Harper vous devriez agir rapidement et
qu'on qu'on cèse de faire de la
partisanerie sur ça puis qu'on s'occupe
des gens qui souffrent des femmes en
premier lieu seconde monsieur un
monsieur toudau notre notre gouvernement
notre pays répond d'une façon
compatissant généreuse et réfléchi les
autres partis disent toujours juste plus
de reféusés plus vite plus de chiffres
mais on a un chiffre qui est très
généreux et on agit d'une façon
responsable il y a juste monsieur Harper
qui pense que il est en train d'agir de
la façon que le Canada toujours agit à
l'échelle internationale on a été un P
pays qui a bénéficié énormément des
vagues successives de réfugiés
d'immigrants et c'est ce son
gouvernement qui est en train de
refermer les portes du Canada
actuellement le système pour aider les
réfugiés ne marche pas comme député je
travaillé avec les les Syriens Canadiens
dans ma communauté c'est vraiment
difficile parce qu'il y a trop de
règlements alors 5 secondes chacun
monsieur monsieur monsieur les Canadiens
veulent un gouvernement qui représente
leur valeur à l'internationale ça manque
cruellement avec Monsieur on a déjà
annoncé des réformes au système de
réfugiés pour accepter des réf reféfugi
plus vite c'est une position responsable
déà c'est déjà le moment dans ce thème
le Canada dans le monde d'une question
pour vous 5 avec 25 secondes pour
répondre notre vous posez cette question
sur le thème comment condamner
l'inacceptable je vous ramène par
exemple autrefois le Canada qui a joué
un rôle actif contre la partille dans le
monde Bran maroney pour ne pas le nommer
l'Arabie Saoudite doit décapiter et
crucifier sous peu un jeune homme de 21
ans qui a comme seul crime manifesté
contre le régime il y a 4 ans ça fait le
tour du monde aujourd'hui seriez-vous
prêt à imposer des sanctions contre
l'Arabie Saoudite si elle procède comme
prévu à l'exécution je vous donne un
exemple de sanctions par exemple
l'annulation d'un contrat militaire on a
vendu pour 15 milliards le Canada a
vendu pour 15 milliards de dollars
de blinder l'an dernier Monsieur MKA
premèreoste on a un exemple encore plus
proche de chez nous Rai Badaoui j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer sa femme ses
enfants vivent à
cherbrok c'est indigne et c'est
complètement barbare d'imposer des
peines de flagélation comme ça il faut
que le Canada continue à suivre un
modèle qu'on a déjà suivi regardez le
bilan des droits humains avant de
conclure une vente monsieur Harper le
fait plus merci monsieur duscep je l'ai
dit tantôt il faut interrompre les
ventes à l'Arabie Saoudite il y a le cas
du jeune homme qui sera décapité c'est
incroyable et R Badaoui aussi on doit
intervenir on doit dénoncer également
l'élection du représentant de l'Arabie
saoudite à la tête de la Commission des
droits de la
personne aux Nations Unies mais c'est
c'est c'est c'est une c'est une moquerie
que que de lire quelqu'un d'un tel pays
à la tête de ce qui devrait être un
comité qui s'occupe des droits de la
personne monsieur Harper on a on a
toujours dénoncé ces incidents comme ça
ce traitement comme ça on est pour les
droits de la personne à travers la
planète c'est la même chose pour la cas
de Monsieur badawii notre gouvernement
dénoncé ça nous avons indiqué que nous
accepterons monsieur Badaoui qui na pas
citoyen canadien à n'importe quel moment
mais ce n'est pas juste de PIR des
travailleurs d'une usine à London pour
ça ce n'est pas de gros bon sens
monsieur trudau le Canada a toujours pu
faire plus pour influencer la situation
dans le monde travaillant avec les
autres pays or depuis 10 ans on a
tellement perdu que tout simplement de
dénoncer c'est plus assez nous nous
devons de travailler avec nos alliés
pour exiger à à à l'international que
les pays commencent à se comporter de
façon pour respecter beaucoup plus les
droits humains et le Canada
malheureusement n'a plus la voix qu'on
avait avant que monsieur Harper devienne
Premier ministre merci Monsieur T madame
mais oui c'est clair que nous avons
allié avec la l'Arabie saudite et
ignorer le Bellin des bus de doigt
humaines ignorer les le bus don le dans
le pays et en même temps nous avons
vendu des armements vers l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est affreux et on va le
terminer merci Madame et Merci à VOUS
CIN c'est le temps est venu de de vous
entendre avec votre conclusion de ce
débat de ce soir vous avez chacun une
minute pour le faire le tirage au sort a
désigné monsieur un pour commencer merci
beaucoup chers amis la situation
économique et politique mondiale demeure
très inquiétante ce n'est pas le temps
de jouer avec notre économie ni avec
notre sécurité qui est le choix de cette
élection est clair qui est prêt à bâtir
un pays sécuritaire et qui peut protéger
notre économie nous avons un plan de
réduction de taxes et d'impôt de
dépenses aborda et efficace et d'un
budget équilibré les Québécois et tous
les can ve des basse d'impôt des emplois
stables un bon avenir pour leurs enfants
un bonne retraite pour nos années ils
veulent que nous les nouveaux citoyens
prêent serment avec visage à visage
découvert ce sont des valeurs des
Québécois ce sont des valeurs
canadienses c'est aussi le bilan et les
priorités de notre gouvernement
conservateur le 19 octobre voter pour
protéger notre économie protéger notre
sécurité protéger nos valeurs merci
monsieur peu monsieur Trudeau vous venez
d'entendre monsieur herper vous dire
qu'au fond on peut pas faire mieux moi
je suis pas en accord avec lui et de
cette île à cherbrook de à à de jusqu'à
saint-élite cxton jusqu'à Montain
jusqu'à Saint-Boniface les gens m'ont
dit à travers le pays que ils sont pas
d'accord avec monsieur Harper on peut
faire mieux j'ai un plan qui va créer
des emplois qui va avoir un impact
direct dans vos vies on va baisser les
impôts pour la class moyenne on va
donner des allocations plus généreuses
aux familles et on va faire des
investissements historiques dans vos
communautés c'est un plan qui va créer
des emplois et de la croissance
économique et qui va mettre plus
d'argent dans vos poches et ça commence
tout de suite monsieur mulkaire pense
qu'on peut attendre des années il a tort
le moment pour investir c'est maintenant
retroussons-nous les les manches nous
pouvons faire mieux ensemble avec votre
appui nous allons faire mieux Monsieur
troudeau Merci monsieur mulker tous les
jours nous voyons les inégalités et les
injustice grandir tandis que les emplois
de qualité et le filet social
disparaissent peu à peu tous les jours
des menace à la paix et à
l'environnement à l'échelle de la
planète nous interpelle ce sont là nos
vrais défis comme société quel héritage
allons-nous laisser à nos enfants et à
nos petitsenfants un pays fermé guerrier
et pollueur au NPD nous avons commencé
quelque chose en 2011 et j'ai tellement
hâte que les progressiste du Québec et
du reste du Canada puissent travailler
ensemble pour bâtir l'avenir de nos
rêves avec mon expérience de 35 ans au
service des citoyens comme votre premier
ministre je prends l'engagement de
continuer de me tenir debout pour vous
au NPD nous avons le leadership et
l'expérience pour battre et remplacer
c'est Stepen Harper avec un gouvernement
qui nous ressemble et qui nous rassemble
on continueci merci Monsieur Madame
merci encore une fois ce soir nous avons
vu les autres chefs qui se chamaillent
les les électeurs sont vraiment fatigués
de ce type de politique moi aussi je
fais les politiques je fais la politique
autrement c'est clair que maintenant
après la décinée de destruction par
monsieur Harper nous avons le grand
rattrapé à faire c'est clair que c'est
pardon Mo la grande rattrapage à faire
c'est urgent c'est urgent que nous
mettent sur pied encore les lois pour
les protections d'environnement pour
suivre les recommandations de la
Commission de Vérité et Réconciliation
d'investir dans les infrastructures des
municipalités d'alléger les dettes
d'étudiant d'agir contre les gaz et de
ser tout c'est possible votez pour les
ver votez pour vous merci Madame le mot
de la fin monsieur du bien merci ce soir
on a enfin parlé des enjeux qui vous
préoccupent j'ai parcouru tout le Québec
pour aller à votre rencontre je vousi
écoué pour bien comprendre vos
inquiétudes vos aspirations vos espoirs
on a parlé des oléodues qui vous
inquiètent de l'assurance emploi de la
gestion de l'offre on a parlé de santé
de relance économique plutôt que
d'austérité on a parlé des droits de la
femme du droit à la pleine égalité vous
m'avez beaucoup parlé de votre
opposition au vote à visage couvert de
votre volonté comme québécoise et
québécois qu'on se tiennent debout vous
avez vu ce soir que nous formons une
seule parti qui représente vraiment le
Québec sur toutes ces questions pour ma
part je suis revenu par conviction pour
le Québec parce que je crois moi aussi
qu'on a tout à gagner se tenir debout
tous ensemble vous pouvez comptez sur
moi moi je compte sur vous bonne fin de
soirée merci Monsieur DUP c'est sur ce
cette note que se termine ce grand débat
qui est le seul débat à vous réunir tous
les cinq alors au nom de tous ceux qui
ont suivi le débat ce soir sur toutes
les plateforme à travers le pays un
immense merci c'est un grand privilège
de vous entendre tous les cinq ensemble
sur le plateau de Radio Canada et en
partenariat avec la presse merci
beaucoup et bonne fin de campagne on va
vous suivre à la trace c'est certain
grâce à des collègues journalistes comme
y Boisvert et patriceoi merci beaucoup
euh à tous les deux madames messieurs ne
manquez pas le grand rendez-vous
électoral du 19 octobre prochain
j'espère que ce ce débat vous aura
inspiré et vous aura motivé à aller
voter le 19 octobre pour exercer votre
droit démocratique très bonne fin de
soirée au revoir à la
prochaine
[Musique]